So, weiter gehts.
Ich hab jetzt ungefähr rausgekriegt, wie man das macht, was ich letztes Mal schon machen
wollte.
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt noch ein bisschen abgucken, aber ich kann euch gleich schon
sagen, die Library, die wir dafür verwenden müssen, ist absoluter Rotz.
Aber eine andere gibt's nicht.
Andere hab ich nicht gefunden bisher.
Und wenn jetzt mal ein paar Leute da sind, also sprich, wenn Twitch gecheckt hat, dass
das Stream on ist, weil es sind immer noch null Zuschauer.
Ich bin schon...
Wie lang bin ich schon?
Sieht man da, wie lang ich on bin?
Ähm...
Okay, 2.50.
Aber normalerweise checkt das Twitch immer sofort.
Ich kann ja mal in Discord gucken.
Ich muss gucken, dass ich nicht auf einem falschen Channel bin.
Oh Gott.
Max!
Hoffentlich bist du nicht auf einem Weebspam-Channel.
Dann ist hier gleich Monka Toss.
Wartet mal.
Ich hoffe, ich bin nicht auf einem falschen Channel, Alter.
Was ist das?
Nein!
Okay, gut.
Ich bin nicht auf einem falschen Channel, Alter.
Ich wollte gucken, ob der Stream angekündigt wurde.
Jetzt gerade, oder?
Jetzt eben.
Deswegen, jetzt sind auch...
Jetzt kommen auch ein paar Leute rein.
Keine Ahnung, was wieder los war mit Twitch.
Ja, wenn ein paar Leute da sind, zeige ich euch noch mal was Lustiges, was ich gerade
gefunden habe auf Twitter.
Progress auf Wumplors Chat.
Jetzt bin ich verhöhnt schon von meinem eigenen Twitch-Chat, Alter.
Das ist hier was.
Der De-Abo ist raus.
Wer namen am Start?
Detikarn hat subscribt für drei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Benutzt du KeyPass oder LastPass?
KeyPass.
LastPass würde ich nie verwenden.
Richtig.
Der Eichler ist mir auch gerade eingefallen, dass De-Abo normalerweise in diesem Kontext
nicht verwendet wird.
Dis-Abo.
Dis-Abo, Alter.
Warum nie LastPass, weil ich nichts verwende, wo meine Passwörter, also quasi die Zugänge
zu den sensibelsten Sachen, die ich irgendwie habe, online gespeichert werden und ich keine
Ahnung habe, was die Software treibt.
Moonbeard Desmond, sechs Monate am Start.
Easy clap, nice.
Easy.
Fatir, ihr hat es erkannt.
Du musst mal unterscheiden zwischen sensibel oder sensitiv.
Wieso hast du X-Server auf dem Desktop, habe ich.
Stimmt.
Warum habe ich einen X-Server auf dem Desktop?
Was ist das für eine gute Frage, warum habe ich einen X-Server auf dem Desktop?
Ich glaube, wir haben mal probiert, ob man nicht mit diesem neuen, mit diesem WSL-Windows-Zeug,
wie es damit aussieht, grafische Programme laufen zu lassen.
Schon ewig her, das heißt, es war noch WSL-1, es wird jetzt schon wieder Zeit, das mit WSL-2
auszuprobieren.
So, jetzt seid ihr ja da, ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Muss ich mich gerade kaputtlachen.
Ich dachte erst, das ist ein G-Bait, aber ich glaube, es ist echt.
Also, Steam macht ja immer schon Werbung für irgendwelche Deals, in dem Fall für das hier.
Das Game juckt mich nicht, ich finde die Antwort witzig.
Ich habe mal ausgeplannet die Antwort, ja.
Stadia Better, und guckt euch mal was von, für einen Lauch, Alter, Stadia Better im Vergleich
zu Steam, oder so ein 8-Jähriger.
Okay, ich sehe schon, der Chat findet es nicht lustig, aber ich fand das übelst lustig.
Okay, mittlerweile gibt es schon eine Antwort drauf, oder irgendwie, was?
Kid, who plays games on Stadia, Red Dead Redemption 2 und Doom Eternal, der sieht nicht so aus,
als dürfte weder Red Dead Redemption 2, noch Doom Eternal überhaupt spielen.
Die Weide ist nicht lustig, genau, es ist ja fucked, es ist ja allgemein bekannt, es steht
überhaupt nicht mehr zur Diskussion, dass Google Stadia besser ist als Steam, das ist
ja schon erwiesen.
Marketing Account, dachte ich auch erst, aber das ist so authentisch, der Account, oh, was
hat denn, was macht denn Merkel wieder?
Was ist da, zeige ich dir mal her, was zum Teufel ist das, yeah, hat die Physik studiert,
hat die nicht Physik studiert, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert, das ist das Kind vom
Alphabet CEO, ich habe ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung, wie der Alphabet CEO heißt,
ist das nicht irgendein Inder, oder ist der neue Google CEO ein Inder, oder er sieht zumindest
irgendwie indisch aus, oder heißt indisch, ich kann das immer nicht auseinanderhalten,
ob Alphabet oder Google, der Google CEO, das Inder durchaus CEO können und nicht nur scammen,
sieht man am Microsoft Chef, der geht ja ab, das hätte was der geschafft haben in Microsoft,
man muss ja ab und zu mal zur Abwechslung seinen Hut ziehen, also das hätte ich vor
10 Jahren oder so, wo der Microsoft, weiß nicht seit wann der Typ Microsoft, seit wann
ist der Microsoft Chef, seit wann ist das hier, 2014, also seit 6 Jahren, also ganz
ehrlich, also 2014 hätte ich im Leben nicht gedacht, dass aus Microsoft mal das unternehmen
wird, was mit die meisten Open Source Contributions und größten Open Source Dinge hat, wobei
das Marketing-Geschwätze ist, bei einem wichtigen Projekt weiß ich nicht, wie sie so drin sind,
dass denen mal GitHub gehört, dass die einen Code-Editor raushauen, den die meisten Leute
verwenden, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, was, nee, Larry Page ist doch der, warte mal,
jetzt bringe ich es durcheinander, nee, Larry Page ist der Googlemensch, der mit dem Facebook
man verwechselt, ah, und wo ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr gay, sehr, sehr gay, Brin oder
wie er heißt, ist das nicht auch irgendein Googlemann, ja, der da, ist das nicht auch
irgendein, Google, Googleman, ah, das ist der Co-Founder von Google, ah, verstehe, exzellent,
der war das, stimmt, so, ok, was hat sie denn wieder angestellt, was hat sie denn angestellt,
vor allem warum sind die ganzen Tweets über Merkel auf Englisch, wahrscheinlich juckt
uns in Deutschland mal wieder überhaupt nicht, was eigentlich abgeht, uns interessiert nur
das, oh, oh, WTF, was ist das, warum hat der Typ sich gelöscht, RIP Stadia Kid, das ging
aber schnell, das ging aber schnell, also entweder, entweder war das wirklich eindeutig
Exposed Fake Account, die Stadia Gang, oder der hat bei mir im Stream zugeguckt und hat
gesagt, fuck, der Max hat mich geflammt, gleich Countdicht machen, aber war das ja nie, naja,
aber ich hab's euch ja noch, guck mal, wir haben keine Frametrops, also heute mal hier,
nix, mal gucken, ob das ganze so bleibt, kaum dürfen die Leute wieder auf die Arbeit fahren
oder in Geschäfte gehen, schon ist hier wieder, hat Vodafone keine Probleme mehr, aber ich
hab's auf Twitter gepostet schon, und ich sag's jetzt hier noch mal im Stream, warum,
warum genau hat der jetzt mal ein Video copy pasted, der Typ ist zu heftig, er nutzt 2020
unironisch LeadSpeak, richtig weggeraised, ja, also ich sag's jetzt auch noch mal hier,
ich bin ja der Ansicht, meine persönliche Meinung ist, Gamer Grill mit Headsetter wirst
so massiv gedisst, echt werde ich, hab ich gar nicht gelesen, ne, da werde ich nicht
gedisst, die anderen oder was, naja, also wenn das schon massiver Dis ist, dann weiß ich
auch nicht, in welchem denn, wo werde ich massiv gedisst, naja, also wenn das jetzt
massiver Dis ist, dann darf er mich ruhig gern weiter massiv, wenn er Spaß dran hat,
so, ja, was wollte ich jetzt mal, genau, ich wollte euch ja eigentlich was auf Twitter
von mir zeigen, und zwar, meine persönliche Meinung ist ja, dass, wenn die jetzt anfangen,
irgendwo hab ich jetzt hier geschrieben, genau, also wenn die jetzt wieder anfangen alles
aufzumachen, und es scheint ja so zu sein, vor allem total uneinheitlich, ja, mal darfste,
mal darfste nicht, mal Eisdiele auf, mal Eisdiele zu, mal Mundschutz, mal keinen Mundschutz,
es blickt im Prinzip keine Sau durch, und ich bin, also meine persönliche Meinung ist,
dass es nicht lange dauern wird, weil du kannst dich auf die Leute absolut nicht verlassen,
meine persönliche Meinung ist, dass das nicht lange dauern wird, und wir machen wieder alles
dicht, oder wir nehmen im Kauf, dass reihenweise Leute abkratzen, eins von beiden, eins von beiden,
wir können auch den Ami-Style machen und uns überlegen, ob man Corona nicht erschießen
kann oder so, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das hier passieren wird, das wird nicht lange
dauern, ich bin, also im Vergleich zu den letzten Tagen, wenn ich so rumgelaufen bin,
da hast du ja auch schon so die üblichen geistig verwirrten Leute am Start gehabt, die am Main
mit fünf Leuten rumgehungen haben, ja, meistens irgendwelche Jugendliche oder so, aber ja,
Weinwegen, aber heute war schon, heute war schon deutlich mehr, und der einzige Unterschied
zu sonst ist, dass die Leute jetzt im Laden eine Maske anziehen müssen, und dass die
Leute jetzt ein bisschen mehr Abstand halten müssen, das ist natürlich schon im Vergleich
zu sonst ein riesen Unterschied, aber ich kann mir vorstellen, umso mehr das Normalität
wird, umso mehr scheißen die Leute drauf, und man hätte es wahrscheinlich heute schon
gesehen, wenn man in einem Supermarkt arbeitet, dass viele Leute wieder diskutieren und rumnerven
und alles in der Richtung, das wird nicht, du kannst dich nicht, du kannst dich nicht
auf die Leute verlassen, das klappt nicht, das weiß ich als IT-Mann ganz besonders, zum
Glück habe ich mit End-User-Support nichts zu tun, aber da ist es auch so, erinnere ich
mich mal wieder daran, wo mir mal einer eine Mail geschrieben hat, mit dem Titel, ich hoffe,
das kriege ich jetzt irgendwie richtig zusammen, das System geht nicht, da habe ich ihr zurückgeschrieben,
ja, ich glaube nicht, dass sie bei mir richtig ist, weiß gar nicht, wie sie meine E-Mail-Adresse
bekommen hat, aber ich kann es weiterleiten, wenn sie mir sagt, um welches System es geht,
und die Antwort war, das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten, nicht einfach nur das System,
mit dem wir täglich arbeiten, die hat geschrieben, natürlich das System, mit dem wir täglich
arbeiten, und da weißt du schon, was du für Leute, für geistig, naja, komische, nicht
auch ganz auf der Höhe Leute hast, und die ist sicherlich nicht blöd gewesen, aber gerade
Leute, die im IT-Support arbeiten, die werden wissen, du kannst dich auf Leute nicht verlassen
und gerade, also wenn du dich schon nicht auf die Leute mit ein bisschen was im Hirn verlassen
kannst, ja, dann kannst du dich garantiert auch nicht auf die Leute, ohne was im Hirn
zu verlassen, das ist wirklich, oi, 3-Head, ganz extrem, das ist 2-Head, da reichen die
3 gar nicht mehr, das war die indische Scam-Mail, ne, das war keine indische Scam-Mail, ich
habe übrigens noch hier MonkaDB-Fahren, weil ich mir gedacht habe, dass das ASCII-Quarium
allein ist zu wenig, ja, bevor wir anfangen, wollte ich noch eine Sache mal loswerden,
weil sich ja auch persönlich an dieser, was mich ein bisschen nervt, an dieser ganzen
Corona-Geschichte, hat überhaupt nichts mit Corona zu tun, null, eine Sache, die mich
schon seit langer Zeit nervt und wo ich mir für die Leute, die da drin arbeiten halt
was besseres wünschen würde, und zwar alle, die jetzt im Krankenhaus arbeiten, oder irgendwie
jeder Arztpraxis im Krankenhaus, irgendwo im Gesundheitswesen, ja, da wo die Leute jetzt
alle rumschleimen, oh, unsere Helden und auch die Politik und die Nachrichten, alles irgendwie
große Schleimattacke startet, das sind die wahren Helden, oder die Supermarktverkäuferin,
das sind die wahren Helden, eigentlich verlassen sich alle viel zu sehr drauf, dass die Leute
das aus Überzeugung machen und selbstverständlich das alles machen, weil ich könnte wetten,
wenn die ganze Corona-Geschichte vorbei ist und wenn diese Leute mal später Probleme
haben mit irgendwas, es wird sich niemand mehr dran erinnern, was sie 2020 gemacht
haben, dass sie 2020 da dabei waren, das heißt, theoretisch das beste, was die jetzt machen
könnten, ist meiner Ansicht nach, die müssten jetzt eigentlich sagen, Jungs, Kohle oder
wir arbeiten nicht mehr, ich weiß, es klingt übelst asozial und das sind halt Leute, die
machen sowas nicht, weil die meisten Leute, es ist ja auch wirklich sehr lobenswert alles,
das sind halt Leute, denen ist es zum größten Teil überhaupt noch was wert, dass die anderen
Leuten helfen können und die würden auch andere Leute nicht im Stich lassen, das Problem
ist aber, dass sich quasi die Chefs von denen und wir alle uns quasi selbstverständlich
darauf verlassen, dass sie das machen und wenn sich alle selbstverständlich darauf verlassen,
sagt man dann, ja gut, dann müssen wir denen auch nicht mehr Geld geben, weil die machen
es ja eh selbstverständlich, das heißt eigentlich müssten die sagen, auch wenn es übelst asozial
wäre und das gerade die Leute in dieser Situation nicht machen würden, die da eh schon arbeiten,
die müssten jetzt sagen, Leute, über 10 Jahre wollen wir jetzt das und das, die unterschreiben
aktuell alles, die unterschreiben aktuell, unterschreiben die alles, natürlich ist das
maximal egoistisch, aber die Leute haben deutlich mehr Geld verdient, die haben deutlich mehr
Geld verdient für den Scheiß, was die machen und das Problem ist, man, das wird sofort
wieder vergessen, sobald die ganze Corona-Geschichte vorbei ist.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn irgendjemand, der, keine Ahnung, der heute im, oder der Krankenschwester,
die gerade im Krankenhaus arbeitet und wirklich Tag ein, Tag aus, die ist fertig, die gibt
wirklich alles, kriegt nicht viel Geld und mal angenommen, die kann in, sag mal, die
kann in 5 Jahren nicht mehr arbeiten, weil sie irgendwie Rückenprobleme hat, kann die
nicht mal als Krankenschwester arbeiten, so, dann gehen die zum Arbeitsamt oder irgendwo
anders hin, meint ihr, das erinnert sich irgendjemand noch daran, dass die 2020 als
Krankenschwester mit dafür gesorgt hat, dass die ganze Corona-Geschichte nicht so ausartet,
das ist den Leuten in 5 Jahren absolut egal, das juckt die, das juckt die, das überhaupt
nicht, da sagen sie, ja, 2020, da hab ich ja gesehen, oh, sie war in der 2020 8 Wochen
krank, da sagt, ja, ich hatte Corona und hatte sonst was, sonst wie, ja, aber 8 Wochen, ne,
ne, da müssen wir ihnen aber 2 Wochen von ihren Gebühren, von ihrem Betrag abziehen,
weil das geht ja nicht, es wird sich kein Mensch dran erinnern, was sie gemacht haben.
Und gerade deswegen, weil alle anderen Leute wahrscheinlich in Zukunft maßlos undankbar
sind, was das angeht, sollten sie jetzt ein bisschen egoistischer sein, sagen, Jungs,
jetzt mehr Kohle, weil jetzt sind wir in einer Situation, wo wir sowas fordern können.
Schonmal über eine Mitgliedschaft in der SPD nachgedacht, weder SPD noch CDU noch sonst
was. Ich sag ja nur, die Leute sollten, die haben deutlich mehr Geld verdient und jetzt
wäre die Variante, wie man das machen könnte. Ich sag nicht, dass es machen soll, das wäre
natürlich auch maximal asozial, aber jetzt wäre die Situation, wo man noch Kohle rausholen
könnte. Ja, und deswegen, das ist voll von Arsch und man muss auch mal sagen, dass ich
das Verhältnis zwischen landlichen Berufen irgendwie ungerechtfertigt finde. Wenn ich
mir überlege, dass irgendein Projektmanagement, Consultant, Dude, keine Ahnung, 180k im Jahr
kriegt, ich sag das jetzt einfach mal so ungefähr über den Daumen von denen, wo ich das so grob
bei manchen weiß, 180k im Jahr kriegt für extrem viel heiße Luft, so Stonks-Menschen,
so extrem viel heiße Luft, die natürlich auch dem jeweiligen Laden, wo die sind, mit
Sicherheit auch Kohle bringen, so ist das nicht, oder zumindest denkt man das. Und ich
weiß nicht, was eine Krankenschwester aktuell verdient, aber ich finde, das steht in keinem
Verhältnis. Das sind richtige Stonks-Typen, genau. Ich finde, das steht in keinem Verhältnis.
Ich sage nicht, dass man dem Stonks-Mensch unbedingt weniger geben sollte, die Verantwortung
wird bezahlt. Ja, das stimmt, aber wenn es danach geht, dann müsste man jemand, der im
Krankenhaus arbeitet, auch mehr bezahlen, weil die haben auch Verantwortung. Die haben
zwar keine Verantwortung, wo es irgendwie um ein paar Millionen Euro geht, aber die
haben Verantwortung, dass ihre Leute da nicht abkratzen, was natürlich die Allgemeinheit
deutlich weniger juckt, als die Verantwortung, ob man ein paar Millionen hat oder nicht.
Also ich will nicht, dass man irgendwelche Leuten weniger Kohle gibt, das ist ja alles
irgendwie okay, wenn irgendjemand bereit ist, ihn für diesen Betrag einzustellen, aber
du müsstest manche Leute schlicht und ergreifend einfach mehr Kohle geben, das kann nicht sein.
Ja, Feuerwehrleute, Sanitäter, es gibt viele Berufe, wo ich sage, ey, das kann nicht sein.
Und letztendlich ist es ja so, solange nicht ein gewisser Druck da verspürt wird, dann
tut sich da auch nichts. Guckt euch doch mal an, in was für einem scheiß Zustand teilweise
Schulen bei uns sind. Was die sich da teilweise überlegt haben, ey. Da frage ich mich immer,
ob die schon mal in den letzten paar Jahren in der Schule gewesen sind. Ja, aber ich kann
ja verstehen, dass das nicht jeder so sieht. Und man muss auch sagen, dass so ziemlich
alles, was gesetzlich versichert ist und du quasi mit deiner gesetzlichen Versicherung
bekommst, sehr großen Ausbeutungscharakter hat. Also sprich, der Vergleich zwischen, man
lässt sich mal privat behandeln und bezahlt das selbst oder eine private Versicherung
und das, was du kriegst, wenn du gesetzlich versichert bist, das ist der Witz, ey. Das
ist das Verhältnis, das ist der absolute Witz. Bei dem einen, krasse das Gefühl, wenn du
zwei Fragen stellst, der will dich am liebsten direkt aus dem Fenster schmeißen. Und bei
dem anderen, der fragt dir nicht, ob dir noch die Ledersätze ranrutschen sollte jetzt.
Erstmal übertrieben gesagt, das ist ein riesen Unterschied dazwischen. Und wenn sie immer
erzählen so nach dem Motto, ja, wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir keine zwei Klassenmedizin
kriegen, totaler Schwachsinn, den haben wir schon. Und der ist auch schon offensichtlich.
Ich machs mittlerweile so, dass wenn ich Kleinkram hab, das ist ja auch der Grund, warum so viel
Zeug operiert wird, das bringt Kohle. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch erzählt hab, meine
Mutter hatte Probleme in der Hüfte hier, irgendwie unten im Rücken und die war zuerst,
zuerst war die beim Hausarzt. So, gesetzlich versichert, beim Hausarzt. Und der Hausarzt
hat gesagt, naja, da ist nichts, schonen, und Tschüss. Nichts untersucht, nix. Ich
hab gesagt, ihr tut es schon vier Wochen weh, nix. Untersucht. Und damals hab ich zuerst
schon gesagt, ey komm, ich such mal ein ordentlicher Autopäde in Frankfurt raus, Canon ordentlich,
der ist bei uns um die Ecke, da ist wirklich 300 Meter Luftlinie weg von da, wo ich arbeite.
Lass uns da mal hin, der rechnet auch im ganz guten Satz ab, das ist nicht so teuer. Ja,
natürlich präsent ist das, was du dafür bezahlt kriegst, auch pauschal, diese Pauschalvergütungsgeschichten
sind komplett für'n Arsch. Das sorgt einfach nur dafür, dass es nicht das Ziel ist, die
Leute gut zu behandeln, oder das sag mal so, das Wohl der Leute im Vordergrund steht,
sondern, dass das irgendwie Profit orientiert ist. Und ich bin da an sich, dass Krankenhäuser
oder auch Arztpraxen, dass das nicht unbedingt, die müssen natürlich gut verdienen, da sag
ich nix dagegen, aber es sollte nicht darauf ausgelegt sein, dass unterm Strich Plus rauskommt.
Das ist okay, wenn das Plus Minus Null rauskommt. Und es ist auch okay, wenn da Minus rauskommt.
Man hat ja dadurch auch was gewonnen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das verlorenes Geld ist.
Frag mal die Leute, die da drin behandelt werden, die sagen bestimmt nicht, oh nee,
oh fuck Minus gemacht, Alter mach dicht. Na zumindest, die war dann zuerst mal im Hausarzt
und der hat halt gesagt, oh nee, hier, juckt mich nicht, mach dich wieder ab. Da ist er
irgendwie ein paar Tage später wieder hingegangen, ist alles nicht besser geworden, da hat er
gesagt, ah, machen wir mal ein bisschen Wärmebehandlung. So, nix, so. Da ist er wieder hingegangen und
dann ist da das Problem, wenn du so oft da hintereinander hingehst, dann hat der Arzt
so die Wahl, der muss sich entweder mit dir beschäftigen, das Problem ist, du warst schon
zweimal da, so richtig abrechnen kann er es nicht mehr. Das heißt, du hast eigentlich
gar keinen Bock. Ich will den Ärzten gar nicht mal unterstellen, dass die nicht wollen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, vielen finden das System auch richtig für'n Arsch. So,
dann hat er ihr irgendwie, irgendeine komische Spritze zum Abschwellen und Schmerzmittel
geschützt gegeben und da ging es ihr kreislaufmäßig schon überhaupt nicht gut. Das ist ja auch
das, was ich euch dann auf Twitter geschrieben hab, wo wir ins Krankenhaus gefahren sind.
So, und dann hatte ich die Spritze nach drei Tagen nochmal geben lassen und dann war es
so heftig, dass wir ins Krankenhaus fahren mussten, nachts. Weil sie irgendwie einen
Puls von, frag mich nicht, 200 oder so, was mit 69 nicht normal ist. Wir sind ins Krankenhaus
gefahren und eins muss man dir sagen, als Notaufnahme, das war echt okay, du konntest
dich nicht beschweren und auf der Station war dann voll für'n Arsch. Komplett für'n
Arsch. Also da hat man gesehen, es geht im Prinzip nicht darum, die Leute gut zu behandeln,
sondern, dass das möglichst kosteneffizient ist und die Leute möglichst schnell wieder
draußen sind. So, und was haben wir dann gemacht? Dann sind wir nach Frankfurt gefahren zu dem
Orthopäde, den ich rausgesucht hab und das haben wir selbst bezahlt und das war von Anfang
an, ich hab mich ja auch schon bei ein paar Sachen selbst bezahlt bei der Behandlung,
deswegen hatte ich ja schon ein bisschen Erfahrung vorher auf was man gucken muss und halt auch
selbst die Erfahrung gemacht, dass es ein riesen Unterschied ist und dann sind wir hingefahren
nach Frankfurt, ohne Scheiß. Allein schon die Terminvergabe war ja, ach jo, eine Sache hab
ich ja vorher gar nicht erzählt, davor war sie ja noch im Krankenhaus beim Orthopäde
und der hat gemeint, er will seine Hüfte operieren. Die hat nichts an der Hüfte, die hat hinten
irgendwas ausgerenkt am Rücken, die hat überhaupt nichts an der Hüfte. Aber schnell mal operieren,
es gibt Kohle. Ja, ich räume hier mal nebenbei auf. So, und wie gesagt, dann sind wir zu
dem Orthopäde nach Frankfurt gefahren und siehe da, die Terminvergabe war schon mal
komplett unterschiedlich wie Tag und Nacht, also sprich, ich mach mal hier eine neue Datei,
was macht man da, header, CPP-File, ach was weiß ich, erstmal alles hinkopieren. Allein
schon die Terminvergabe war ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht, da hast du angerufen,
hast gesagt, hier, wir haben Schmerzen im Rücken, wie sieht's aus? Zwei Tage später,
da fuck, bei den anderen wartest du ein halbes Jahr drauf. Darfobi, fünf Monate, dankeschön.
So, und dann sind wir dahin, dann sind wir dahin, so und was hat er am Ende gemacht?
Einmal eingerenkt und nochmal an die richtige Stelle eine Schmerzspritze gegeben, aber eine,
die ein bisschen mehr kostet, deutlich besser verträglich ist und ohne Scheiß, Leute, die
hat sich da, glaub ich, zwei oder drei Monate mit rumgequält. Nach einer Woche war es fast
wieder weg, da sind wir nach einer Woche nochmal hin und haben das nochmal kontrollieren lassen,
der hat das nochmal abgetast, nochmal geultraschaltet und guckt nochmal, ja, muss ich auf jeden
Fall nochmal ein paar Wochen schonen, aber die Entzündung ist auf dem Ultraschall schon
fast wieder weg und wenn was ist, sollen wir nochmal vorbeikommen. Easy, ja, dafür
waren wir da halt auch eine halbe Stunde drin beim ersten Mal, sprich, die wurde wirklich
eine halbe Stunde lang behandelt, das hast du normalerweise, wenn du das gesetzlich bezahlst
nicht, da wirst du never eine halbe Stunde behandelt, da wirst du vielleicht, wenn du
Glück hast, eine halbe Stunde im Wartezimmer sitzen gelassen, wenn eher eine Stunde und
danach wirst du zwei Minuten behandelt. Was hat der eigentlich vor Schmerzen? Warum will
das hier nicht? Ach, kacke Sprache, äh. So, und ich installiere mal schon die Library
nebenbei. So, und die Sache ist jetzt halt die, die Behandlung hat jetzt was uns selber
gekostet, aber die hat halt auch einfach was gebracht. So, und was hab ich davon, wenn
ich gesetzlich versichert bin, Riesen aufrissen machen muss und zu zwanzig Ärzten und sich
nix tut, ist jetzt doch einfach nur Stress für alle. So, ähm, hast du beim Termin machen
gesagt, dass du privat bezahlst? Ja, weil, also und, weil auf dem seine Homepage steht,
dass er halt nur privat macht. Der hat gar keine, kann sogar nicht gesetzlich versichert.
Und das ist halt wieder mal ein richtig krasser Unterschied gewesen, wo man gesehen hat, dass
unser Gesundheitssystem für'n Arsch ist. Ob der Login auch funktioniert? Ach, ich hab
im Helperfall die Includes vergessen. Wat? Achso, hab ich nicht connected. Ja, und das
ist ein Ding. Wat? Ja. Ok. Bescheuerte Fehlermeldung, ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich das connecten
will. So, ähm, also es ist anscheinend grad wirklich so, das einzige, was es dir bringt,
gesetzlich versichert zu sein ist, du kannst zum Arzt in eine Krankmeldung holen, weil
du eine Erkältung hast und du verreckst nicht, weil du nur als rufen kannst und behandelt
wirst, dass du zwar jetzt nicht akut instant stirbst. Dafür ist es gut, dafür ist es auch
nicht verkehrt, dass wir sowas haben. Ähm, wenn du wirklich gut behandelt werden wirst,
du musst es selbst bezahlen. Du hast, du hast keine Möglichkeit mehr. Oder du findest wirklich,
also oder man hat echt Glück und findet irgendwas Gutes in der Nähe. Aber die Chancen werden
immer, werden immer geringer. Oh, achso, vielleicht soll ich mal Delay rein machen. Ja, und ich
war ja auch schon bei ein paar Sachen, die ich selbst bezahlt hab. Jetzt, ich, ich, ich
weiß halt nicht, ob es sich bei mir lohnt, wenn ich mich privat versichern lassen würde.
Ähm, ich mein, ich bin jetzt 35, das heißt, das ist eigentlich das Jahr, wo man sagt,
man sollte sich spätestens entscheiden, ob man gesetzlich bleibt oder sich privat versichern
lässt. Aber bisher mach ich so, die teuren Sachen, die mach ich halt über die gesetzliche
Kasse, sprich, wenn man irgendwie mal sich röntgen lassen muss oder muss man MRT machen
lassen, das ist halt übelst teuer. Ähm, so Kleinkram oder halt auch, sagen wir so Kleinkram
bis Mittelkram, mach ich mittlerweile rein privat bezahlt selbst. Einfach weil es sackt,
wenn man, wie man gesetzlich versichert behandelt wird. Und es ist, es ist ein Unterschied
wie Tag und Nacht. Ich war beispielsweise beim, beim, äh, Halsnasen, Ohren, Stellarzt
in, hallo, ich will, ich will, ich will den Zug ausmachen. Der, der Zug geht nicht aus,
Leute. Der Zug, ich kann den Zug nicht beenden. Steuerung C. Ist ja fast wie bei der Bahn.
Nur umgedreht, da kommt der Zug und geht nicht weg. Na gut, zack, killen wir's halt, auch
gut. So, also. Wie kriegt man den Zug? SL. Bin SL. Die Lösung ist einfach reich sein,
ja, das stimmt. Ich muss ja sagen, ähm, es wird ja immer gesagt so nach dem Motto Geld,
äh, Geld macht nicht glücklich. Also, ich finde so pauschal kann man das nicht sagen.
Weil wenn man gesunder ist, hat man durchaus größere Chancen glücklich zu sein. Du hast
mit Kohle auf jeden Fall weniger Probleme. Ich mein, es müssen, es müssen jetzt nicht
Millionen sein. Aber wenn man sich überlegt, ab wann man schon, ich hab letztens den Artikel
gelesen, ab wann man schon, ähm, als reich gilt oder sag mal, oder was, nicht, ich weiß
nicht, ob's reich ist oder ab wann man in Deutschland schon ab, ähm, als wohlhabend
oder so gilt. Das ist der Witz. Ich, ich hab jetzt die Zahlen nicht mehr im Kopf. Was
ist denn das irgendwie? Irgendwie kein 45k im Jahr oder so. Irgendwie ganz merkwürdig,
ey. Und das liegt da dran, weil, das glaubt man gar nicht so niedrig, ist das. Müssen
wir mal gleich raussuchen. Man glaubt gar nicht, wie niedrig das ist. Und das liegt
einfach da dran. Weil sau viele Leute so wirklich gerade an der Grenze leben, wo sie irgendwie
über die Runden kommen. Es kann man nicht wirklich reich nennen, aber quasi ab wann
man, ab wann man zu den, zu den oberen so und so viel gehört. Wir reden jetzt nicht
von eins und zehn Prozent, aber zu, zu, zu, zu der Gruppe, die, die mehr hat als, als
der Rest. Das ist total wenig. Ich weiß nicht, ob es 45k im Jahr ist. Wir müssen, das ist
total wenig. So viel glaubt man gar nicht. Ja. Genau, der Durchschnitt, der Durchschnitt
liegt bei wie viel im Jahr? Im Monat, im Monat ist ein übelster Scheißwert, weil ich krieg
14 Monatsgelder. Ich kann das nicht im Monat rechnen. Ähm, ich muss das, ich muss das
im Jahr rechnen. Ja, der Durchschnitt, der Durchschnitt liegt bei, das ist halt, das
ist fast nix. Ähm, hier in Hessen, in Hessen gibt es das vielleicht auch mal irgendwie
im Jahr. Ich weiß nicht. Ähm, ne ne ne, das war das nicht. Ich hab irgendeine komische
Grafik letztens gesehen. Da haben sie so gezeigt, wie viel, ab wann du quasi über der Grenze
bist, wo irgendwie dann 50% unter dir sind. Und das ist, das ist viel weniger als man
denkt. Gut, das ist die Armutsgrenze, das ist wieder was ganz anderes. Ähm, ja, oh,
fuck. Wenn du dir überlegst, dass du quasi ab 3400 Euro, ok, das ist jetzt im Monat,
das ist jetzt, sag mal im Monat, dass du ab 3400 Euro, als quasi in Anführung, als
Reich, da steht netto, ich weiß, dass da netto, der Brutto, das hält das ja auch fast jeder.
Ja, dass du da als Reich giltst. Ähm, Reich, Reich ist was, wo man, wo man denkt, ey, geh
mal hier Millionen oder so. Einkommen Single-Aushalt. Ich hab letztens eine schönere Statistik.
Ja, genau, nicht Reich, Oberschicht. Ähm, es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall, ähm, wer als
Single mehr als 3400, 3400 Euro netto im Monat zur Verfügung hat, gehört zur Oberschicht.
Es ist, also das ist jetzt nicht wenig oder so, aber das ist nicht das, was ich mir, was
ich so quasi unter Reich, äh, im Kopf habe, ja. Ja, sowas hier. Das, das Tool, das Tool
ist schön. Hier, hier sieht man es. Und man sieht hier auch, guckt mal, guckt euch das
mal an, dass, äh, was, ich will nicht Paare ohne, ich will Alleinlebende. Hier, 50%. So,
wenn du über, also der Durchschnitt ist wohl, ist wohl, ist wohl über 1859. So. Aber wenn
die hoch geht, das ist, guckt mal. Du hast, du hast dann, du hast dann quasi mehr als
80% der Leute in Deutschland. NWTF, das ist viel niedriger, als man denkt. Ja, zumindest,
wie gesagt, ich hab den letzten Artikel drüber, ich hab gedacht, das ist viel, ich hätte
mir das viel höher vorgestellt, alles. So, und, ähm, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie
man draufgekommen, gekommen sind, ehrlich gesagt. Ist auch egal. Ähm, ich hab mich,
ich hab mich mal wieder über irgendwas, über irgendwas ausgelassen. Äh, also was ich verdiene,
kann ich euch nicht genau sagen. Nur so der, nur so der, der, vom Anhaltspunkt her, ich
arbeite ja nur vier Tage die Woche. Ich bin im, fuck, in welchem Tarifvertrag bin ich,
ich hab's irgendwann mal im Stream gezeigt. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, bei welcher Gruppe
ich bin. Ich hab, ich vergesse das, ich vergesse das immer. Was man auch, was man auch schon
als Indiz dafür sehen könnte, dass es mir eigentlich zu gut geht. Wenn, wenn du, wenn
du hier irgendwo rumkrebst, wenn du hier irgendwo rumkrebst, dann weißt du sehr genau, in welchem
Tarifvertrag, in welcher Gruppe und was jeder Euro herkommt und was jeder Euro macht. Garantiert,
das musst du wissen, weil sonst bist du im Arsch. So. Allein schon dafür, dass ich das
nicht weiß, ist das wahrscheinlich schon ein Indiz, für das es mir eigentlich viel zu
gut geht. Ähm, also ich bin im, im Tarifvertrag für, Tarifvertrag für Versicherung? Versicherung,
glaube ich. AGV, AGV, Tarifvertrag, das klingt, glaube ich, gut. Ja, ja, ja, da bin ich, da.
Da, so was, blubblubblub. Äh, Gehalts-Tarifvertrag. Ich bin da, glaube ich bin da. Da oder da,
ich glaube da, da bin ich drin in der Gruppe. Also sprich, das ist das, da könnt ihr euch
ungefähr vorstellen, ich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich euch überhaupt sagen darf, wie viel
es genau sind, aber da könnt ihr euch ungefähr vorstellen, das ist das unterste, unter den
es nicht gehen kann. Also sprich, das ist das mindeste, was im Tarifvertrag vereinbar,
fuck, vereinbart ist. So und, wenn man sich überlegt, dass ich nur vier Tage arbeiten
gehen muss, ich gebe ja auch kaum was aus. Also ich bin nicht absichtlich sparsam, ähm,
aber es gibt wenig wofür ich was ausgebe. Du hast ja Leute, die haben wenig Kohle und
schmeißen das Geld zum Fenster raus. Ähm, oder ich gebe kaum was aus. Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, kannst du die Seite mit dem Diagramm mal verlinken, das hier? Ja, also ich komm
wahrscheinlich auch ohne Probleme mit dreimal die Woche oder so aus. Dazu kommt ja bei mir
mittlerweile aber auch noch ein bisschen anderes Zeug. Ich mein, ich mach grad wenig YouTube,
ja, meine Twitch-Aktivität hält sich auch, hält sich auch in Grenzen. Das heißt, ich
verdiene nicht wahnsinnig viel, aber dadurch, dass ich jahrelang Amazon Reflinks gespammt
habe, ein bisschen Twitch Prime, ein bisschen YouTube und Zeug, ein bisschen was krieg ich
auch so im Monat. Nicht viel, nicht viel. Das ist wirklich nicht der Wahnsinn. Ähm,
das kommt auch nochmal dazu. Klar, wenn ich jetzt voll die Woche arbeiten gehen würde,
bekomme ich, würde ich wahrscheinlich noch mehr bekommen, aber es ist viel entspannter,
so wie es jetzt ist. So, ähm, so viele Taten. Zumindest schauen wir mal, was das Mindeste
ist. Ja, da kommt noch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, äh, vertragsspezifische Sachen dazu. Eventuell
auch noch ein bisschen Bonus am Ende des Jahres. Äh, was hast du für nen Stuhl? Ein Mr. Sedus
24. Ne, ein Mr. Sedus Mr. 24, so rum. Was sagst du dazu, dass bei mir im Studium in IT-Sicherheit
Zoom benutzt wird? Zoom ist dieses Videokonferenz-Ding, ne? Was jetzt voll im Trend ist. Ich hab
keine Ahnung, gut Zoom oder schlechtes. Äh, machst du einfach weniger Stunden in der Woche
oder hast du pauschal einen Tag frei? Ich arbeite montags nicht, ja. Benutzt du KeyPass oder
das was? KeyPass. Bei Springer gibt es gerade viele Progas, Bücher kostenlos, vielleicht
sind auch welche für dich dabei. Schick mal Blitz Link, da gucken wir uns das zusammen
an. Kompletter Fail. Also eins muss man ja über Microsoft Teams sagen, ich muss jetzt
echt mal anfangen. Eins muss man ja über Microsoft Teams sagen, das hat ein paar Macken,
aber groß und ganz funktioniert es wirklich gut für ein Microsoft Produkt. So, ich zeig
euch mal die Library, die wir verwenden jetzt dafür. Weil ich hab mir ja in den Kopf gesetzt,
wir wollen ein Over-the-Air-Update machen, also sprich ich will meine Microcontroller
aktualisieren können, übers WLAN, ähm, über HTTPS, also über SSL. Und ich war mal wieder
so richtig big brain, dass ich mir was ausgesucht hab, was es anscheinend nicht gibt. Und was
bisher keiner gemacht hat, ähm, und irgendwie auch sonst keiner machen will. Ich weiß auch
nicht warum, es gibt nichts fertiges. Es gibt nichts fertiges dafür. Das heißt wir
müssen das selbst machen. Über HTTP ist kein Problem, da gibt es sich Web-Server. Sucht
ihr Anwendungsentwickler? Ja, wir suchen, so gut wie immer, Programmierer, Anwendungsentwickler.
Programmierer reduziert ja die Leute ein bisschen zu sehr. Also wir suchen immer Anwendungsentwickler.
Hä, ähm, irgendwas wollte ich gerade noch sagen. Achja, die Progress-Bücher, die Progress-Bücher
wollten wir uns kurz angucken. Das kommt mir bekannt vor, die Musik. Ah, ja, hab ich nie
durchgespielt. Ähm, ok, also, Springer, das ist doch nicht Bild-Zeitung. Wo gibt's die
ganzen Bücher? Hier, Free Books. Ach, Download, All. Achso, ein Ref-Link für die Bewerbung.
Ne, aber solltest du dich bei einer Bank in Frankfurt bewerben, kannst du mich ja vorher
mal fragen, ob ich da nicht arbeite, weil, dann, ähm, dann empfehle ich dich und dann
kann ich dann erst das Monatsgehalt, oder ich glaube sogar den ersten zwei Monatsgehalte
kassieren. Als, ähm, äh, Werbungs-, äh, Programm. So, wo steht denn, wo steht denn
was die alles für Bücher haben? Ich will jetzt, ich will mir nicht unbedingt alles
runterladen, ich will erst mal sehen, was die eigentlich alles haben. Hier, Springer-Announcement,
ja. Und wo sieht man jetzt was die für Bücher? Hier, Archiv. What? Zweiter Link, Full List.
Hier. Ah, yes. Lieber Office, wusste gar nicht, dass ich den Crab installiert hab. Also,
was haben sie mir zu bieten? Juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt mich nicht, juckt
mich nicht. Auch nicht, auch nicht. Wo sind denn die Programme? 400? What the fuck? Brustkrebs.
Nein, will ich mich überhaupt nicht angucken. Äh, sind die nach, sind die nach, nach Themen
irgendwie sortiert? Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken, dann krieg ich ja drei, drei
Stunden. Nach Kategorien? Wie? Ah, Product Type. German Books. Wo ist denn die Kategorie?
Ah, hier. Rasta. Ok, also. Religion, Philosophie raus, Social Science, Science, Science, Science,
Science. Physik und Astronomie, Medizin, Mathematik, Statistik. Oha, mal gucken. Intelligent Technologies.
Oh, das ist Mega Man. Glaub ich. Das ist Mega Man? Ja, oh, huge Musik. Äh, was mit Menschen,
gehen wir bloß fort. Energie, BWL Crap, Computer Science, können wir mal den Rest weg. Was bleibt
da noch übrig? Einfach mal. Äh. Äh. Äh. Sind wir noch so viel? Das kann ich mir jetzt
nicht angucken, das ist zu viel. Ok, wir machen jetzt mal Education, Engineering, machen wir
alles weg, wir machen bloß Computer, Computer Science. Ah, nur Computer, nur Computer Science.
So, wie viele Bücher haben wir da? Was? Warum sind das immer noch 406? Ach nee. Ach guck
mal, das überspringt das. Ok, ich bin zu dumm für Excel. Aber ihr wisst, ich verwende
Excel nicht. Ich kann mich mit Excel nicht auskennen. Noch nie Excel benutzt? Ja, einmal
oder so. Ich hab mich ja schon gewundert, dass ich überhaupt LibreOffice installiert
hab. Äh, ok, also das interessiert mich nicht so wirklich. Das könnte relativ interessant
sein. La. LaTeX. Brauchst du noch die Excel Tool? Oh, da hab ich mich auf der Arbeit glücklicherweise
vorgedrückt. Ähm. Automaten und Computability. Äh, nee. Design, UML. Boah. Ich glaub, ich
hab irgendwie gefühlt jede Menge Subs übersehen, kann das sein? Ich muss da mal kurz reingucken.
Da ich nicht für die Hälfte übersehen hab. Das wäre ziemlich MonkaS. Wen haben wir denn
hier am Start? Äh, Heinrich hat Subscribed. Sechs Monate, Dankeschön. Huge Sub. Und
da Fobi auch, fünf Monate. Dich hatt ich glaub ich schon, aber trotzdem, Dankeschön
für die ganzen Subs. Nicht lull. Wollte ich gar nicht drücken. Als wollte ich drücken.
UML, Power Plus Off. Äh, ok, Foundations for Designing User Sentences. Computer Vision
Data Mining, Simple Geometry, Hanzo. Autografie, Eye Tracking, Machine Learning. Oh, haben wir
hier für unsere ganzen Mathe-Fans. Nope, nope, nope. Concise Guide to Software Engineering.
Das Pison Workbook, vielleicht nicht schlecht. Fundamentals Multimedia, vielleicht, kein
Schimmer. Äh, jede Menge Pison-Programmierung. Object-Oriented Analysis. Oh, nee, das mir
zu harte kost. Introduction to Data Science, Concise Guide to Databases, Digital Image
Processing. Irgendwas, wo ich jetzt sagen würde. Ja, ja, das interessiert mich voll.
Statistics, Guide to Competitive Programming. Das könnte tatsächlich interessant sein. Das
habe ich sogar letztens mal in einem Video als Empfehlung gehört, diesen Guide to Competitive
Programming. Der könnte wahrscheinlich ganz, ganz gut sein. Äh, Introduction to Artificial
Intelligence. Nee. Scala. Java. Geh fort. Ich weiß, das mit Java nichts zu tun hat, aber
ist Scala nicht auf JVM-Basis? BWL-Crap. Oh, das war's für mich. Guide to Scientific
Computing in C++. Endlich. Herz390. Hallo. Äh, oh, das ist ja, ist ja das Doppelpack.
Wenn du denkst, es kann kaum noch schlimmer werden, kommt die Java-Grundlage danach. Logical
Foundation of Cyber-Physical Systems. Fortran. Was ist denn mit denen los? Aus 2018. Es gibt
ein Buch aus 2018 über Fortran. Ich hätte erwartet, es ist ein Buch von 1970 oder so.
System Programming in Unix-Linux. Das könnte ganz interessant sein. Parallel Computing vielleicht
auch. Eine ist es für Computer. Java into Semesters. Beginner. Die könnten, die, ich
glaube die Dinger sind sogar ganz gut hier. Ich, ich, ich bilde mir ein, das habe ich
schon mal irgendwo als Empfehlung gelesen, die zwei Pausenbücher. So, aber Leute, ich
habe geschrieben, wir machen Progress. Wir machen jetzt auch Progress. Und zwar, jetzt
pass mal auf, jetzt geht es ab. Bam. Bam. Also, das Ziel ist ja, dass ich meine Micro-Controllers,
also unter anderem die hier, updaten kann über das WLAN. Und über das WLAN updaten
gibt es zwei verschiedene Varianten. Entweder man legt die neue Firmware irgendwo auf einen
Server drauf und lässt die sich von seinem Controller per HTTP pullen von einem Server.
Das ist interessant. Mal angenommen, man ist Hersteller von einer smarten Steckdosenleiste,
sowie CoGeek. Die CoGeek Steckdosenleiste, die hat ja einen ESP866 drin. Und mal angenommen,
ich bin ein Hersteller einer smarten Steckdosenleiste. Und ich möchte alle meine Geräte auf der
Welt die Möglichkeit geben, mit neuer Firmware versorgt zu werden. Dann würde ich diese Methode
nehmen. Dann würde ich nämlich auf einen Server bei mir signierte Firmware Package legen,
neue Firmware. Und würde einfach sagen, okay, ich biete neues Update an. Und dann kriegen
die Leute dann ein Pop-Up und klicken drauf und dann lädt es von meinem Server das Firmware
Update runter und überhaltet TPS und macht das Update und gut ist. So, das ist die eine
Variante. Was ich machen will, ist die umgedrehte Variante. Ich will nicht, dass das Gerät
sich das Update pullt vom Server, sondern ich will das Update auf das Gerät pushen.
Und das gibt, es gibt schlicht und ergreifend, ums Verr- ich hab GitHub rauf und runter abgesucht.
Es gibt nichts fertiges dafür. Über HTTPS ist das gar kein Problem, da gibt es ein paar
fertige Sachen und man kann es auch relativ easy selbst machen. Aber über HTTPS findet
man eh verdammt wenig. Auf dem ESP32. Das liegt zum größten Teil daran, weil der ESP32
halt auch nicht viel RAM hat. Ich glaub 80 Kilo Byte oder so. Weiß nicht, wie viel RAM
das Ding hat. Ja, 160, 160K. Und ich glaube, das teilt man sich auch mit, also das ist
nicht reiner RAM, das teilt man sich glaube ich auch mit irgendwelchen statischen Sachen
aus dem Sketch und so. Also wir können ja mal gucken, ob wir ausgeben lassen können,
wie viel RAM man hat. ESP, irgendwie Heap. GetFreeHeap. Gucken wir mal. Wir geben uns
mal den RAM aus, den wir haben. Also da sieht man schon, das Ding ist relativ beschränkt,
was RAM-Size ist. Wie viel hast du für deinen TinyPico bezahlt, die 40€ oder wie? 20 Dollar?
Also irgendwie mit Versand wahrscheinlich. Also ich hab 10 Stück bestellt gleich. Wahrscheinlich
mit Versand ein bisschen mehr als 20€. So, ich kanns dir genau sagen. Bye. So, ich glaube
ich hab da bestellt, ne zu teuer. Da oder da hab ich bestellt, eins von beiden, genau.
So, stellst du dir klein mal 10 Stück. Add to Cart. 200 Dollar. Eats AF. Checkout. So,
continue. Ich will einfach nur sagen, was Shipping. Ok, wir geben jetzt mal Fake ein.
Ich will einfach nur zum Shipping. Shipping. So, Blob, Blob, Blob, Blob in Germany. Germany.
6 0 3 2 9 Frankfurt. Frankfurt. Hessen. Phone Number. Ok, genau. 15 Dollar kostet's. Was?
Ja gut, ab spätestens wir, jetzt machen wir nicht weiter. Also 15 Dollar Tracked Package,
Tracked Post. Das heißt du bezahlst am Ende 115 Dollar. Also das heißt du bezahlst ziemlich
genau 200€ für 10 Stück. Du kannst natürlich auch weniger nehmen, ne? Aber die Versandkosten,
also ist halt die Frage, ob sich das so sehr lohnt, ne? Ich bestell mir bei fast allen mittlerweile
10er Packs. Ich hab am Anfang den Fehler gemacht und hab bei vielen Sachen, auch bei
kleinen Elektronikkram, hab ich immer eins bestellt. Und du machst so kleine Teile, in
den ersten Teilen die Pico hab ich schon gefetzt, ja. Aber weil ich zu doof war. Ich hab die
WLAN Antenne abgebrochen aus Versehen, weil ich zu sehr dran gezogen hab. Kann man wieder
fixen, kann ich dran löten, ist kein Problem. Hab ich bloß noch nicht gemacht. Ähm, so.
Und, äh, deswegen, ich bestell mir bei allen Elektronikdingern mittlerweile entweder 5
oder 10. Oder halt 3, wenn's das anderweitig nicht gibt. Es ist, es ist wirklich sinnvoll,
sich mehrere Sachen zu bestellen, weil so Kleinkram, gerade wenn man sich beispielsweise
irgendwelche Sensoren holt oder sonst was, die macht man so schnell mal kaputt und dann
hat man keinen Ersatz da. Ich hab mittlerweile von den meisten Sensoren halt auch hier ein
paar liegen. Also quasi, so Sachen die man immer braucht, paar Widerstände, die gängigsten
Sensoren, paar Spannungswandler, da hab ich immer genug da, dass man einfach auch mal
Ersatz hat. So, ähm, also wir sehen wir haben freien Speicher, das sind wahrscheinlich
Bites, denk ich mal. Bites to Megabytes. Nein, Google. Ja, schon besser. Also wir haben
250, 250 Kilobyte RAM auf dem ESP gerade. Das ist, äh, das ist sogar mehr als ich gedacht
hab, ehrlich gesagt. Ich dachte es ist weniger. Ähm, aber man sieht, man kann da keine allzu
großen Sprünge machen. Also sprich 250 Kilobyte. Wir haben weniger als 1 MB RAM. Und in meinem
Desktop Rechner sind gerade 32 Gigabyte. Also da sieht man mal was das Hardware mäßig
so vom Vergleich her ist, ja. Ähm, okay, aber ich hab gesagt wir wollen ein bisschen
Progress machen. Gut. Also wir nehmen diese Library hier. Die hab ich im Vorfeld schon
rausgesucht. Habe ich es nicht eben schon mal auf. Ja. Den ESP32 HTTPS Server. Ich hab,
ich hab da wie gesagt schon ein bisschen mit rumgespielt. Das heißt ich kann jetzt auch
ein bisschen abgucken vorher. Ich hab, ich hab hier, also ich will jetzt nicht sagen
ich mach das alles komplett blind und ist es nicht. Also ich hab schon ein paar Sachen
im Vorfeld ausprobiert und ich hab echt gekämpft mit dem Ding. Also die Library ist bei weitem
nicht bugfrei und hat echt ein paar sehr merkwürdige Designentscheidungen. Das werden wir aber
gleich sehen. Ich installiere das ganze das erste Mal. Ähm, aber es ist das einzige was
ich gefunden habe, was auf dem ESP32 Arduino Kram funktioniert und einen HTTPS Web Server
mit TLS bzw. SSL HTTPS hat. Ansonsten hab ich nix gefunden. Das Ding ist so verbugged,
ihr werdet es gleich sehen, diese Library ist so verbugged, dass wenn ich die Verbindung
abbreche, dann muss ich den ESP neu starten, dass der Server sich wieder, wieder einkriegt.
Das Ding ist schon ganz schön im Arsch. YouTube Money klingt halt, wenn man sich direkt für
200 Euro ESPs kauft. Das hat ja mit YouTube Money, ja das ist schon nicht unreich, aber
es ist einfach preisleistungsmäßig sinnvoller sich gleich 10 Stück zu kaufen. Die sind natürlich
viel zu teuer, muss man auch mal sagen. Also ich empfehle das, übrigens wo war ich jetzt
schon. Also ich empfehle euch nicht die Dinger zu kaufen, wenn ihr nicht eh schon ein bisschen
damit rum spielt. Wenn ihr anfangen wollt ESP32 zu programmieren, ist es viel, viel
einfacher. Ihr kauft euch z.B. eine NodeMCU. Die kannst du dir bei Amazon.de kaufen für
ein Apple und ein i. Hier, ATS Delivery. Ne, das ist die falsche ESP. Das ist die
ESP32866. Die gibt es teilweise bei Amazon, auch schon Amazon.de. Für 8, 9, hier. Ne.
Ja gut, hier kriegst du 3 Stück. 5 Stück. Haben die keine? Das sind die 9, da muss
man aufpassen. Das sind die mit USB, wofür es noch nichts gibt. Okay, ja, also gibt es
bei AliExpress günstiger. Aber wenn ihr einfangen wollt, kauft euch lieber so ein Board. 1, 2.
Wie gesagt, ich würde immer 2 kaufen oder klein 3. Die sind nämlich schon komplett
fertig. Die haben mehr Pins als der Tiny und die haben natürlich schon alles vorgelötet.
Ihr müsst hier gar nichts machen. Und was können diese Tiny Picos mehr? Die können
nicht mehr, die können kleiner sein. Das ist der einzige wirkliche Vorteil von den Dinger,
dass die klein sind. Und die sind halt extrem klein. Die sind so klein wie mein Daumennagel,
siehst du hier im Vergleich zu einer AA-Batterie. Die sind einfach klein. Das heißt, wenn man
die Dinger irgendwo einbauen will, hinter eine Dose in die Wand oder so, da sind natürlich
super dafür. Da sind die normalen NodeMCUs ein bisschen dick. Die sind ungefähr, so
ein NodeMCU ist ungefähr ein Zentimeter kleiner als ein Raspberry Pi Zero. Ja. Hi Max, gibt
es eine Möglichkeit, wenn man auf einem deutschen System einen Double generiert, der mit Komma
getrennt ist, in Punkttrennung umzuwandeln und damit man das richtig in einer Datenbank
speichern kann, ohne es vorher in ein String zu kommen. Ja, du kannst, warte mal, ne. Du
musst das nicht umwandeln. Wenn es ein Float ist und du speicherst es in die Datenbank,
dann ist das vollkommen egal. Der Punkt und die, es gibt gar keinen Punkt und Komma in
der internen Speicherung von so einem Float, wie du dir das vorstellst. Wenn du einen Double
oder einen Float hast, dann ist es egal, ob Deutsch oder Englisch. Deutsch oder Englisch
wird erst interessant, wenn du es in ein String umwandeln willst. Davor ist es egal. Wenn du
eine Zahl als Double hast, gibt es kein Deutsch und Englisch. Da gibt es nur Double oder
Float oder Long oder Long Long oder U Long oder was auch immer. Float ist so der Überbegriff.
Kleid, Kleidkomma, Fließkomma, Kleidkomma. Ich bin ja eher für Kleidkomma. Was kann man
mit dem ganzen Zeug machen? Bei meiner Schule, beim PC-Raum liegen nur solche Dinge rum.
Ein Schüler hat einfach die Dinger auf den Boden geschmissen. Da würde ich den Schüler
erst mal anscheißen, warum er einen Dinger auf den Boden schmeißt. So, also, Leute, Max,
ich habe nicht mehr lang Zeit. Konzentriert. Also, wir haben nichts gemacht heute. Also,
ich habe die Library jetzt installiert. Wie gesagt, Fragen gehen bei mir nicht verloren.
Fragen werden hier mitgelockt. Also, ich werde das nachher noch alles beantworten. So, also,
was wir jetzt machen ist, wir gehen jetzt mal auf die Seite und gucken uns den Example-Code
an. Das ist nämlich recht easy, recht easy zu benutzen. HTML Forms. Das heißt, wir werden
zuerst, wir machen, wir machen es gleich mit HTTPS. Das Ziel ist, das Ziel ist ja, dass
wir das mit HTTPS machen, aber erst gleich. Also, Examples. So, wir nehmen uns das Formsexample,
weil wir Sachen pushen wollen. Und, ja, ich zeige euch jetzt mal gleich, ich zeige euch
erst mal, was für eine krasse Qualität diese Library hat. Self-Signed. Wo ist das Beispiel
mit Self-Signed? Hier, Self-Signed-Zertifikat. Ich will es euch noch mal beispielsweise zeigen,
mit was für einer doch etwas, ja, sagen wir noch, Optimierung, Optimier-Library mit Optimierungsbedarf
wir uns hier zu tun haben. Also, erst mal die ganzen Headers include. Ich gebe dir Header.
So, HTTPS. Watt? Watt, ich hab's doch installiert. Was hat er für Schmerzen? Hab ich, hab ich
die Library eben installiert, oder? Jetzt bin jetzt wir im Kopf. Install. Build. Ah,
ich hab Using-Namespace vergessen. Wir sind ja C++, ganz vergessen. Sah der Code gestern
ich so, doch. Ah, jetzt funktioniert's. Jetzt muss ich noch mal neu starten, nur dass er
meine Header gecheckt. Ich hab mich mal wieder zum Labern hinreißen lassen. Aber jetzt machen
wir noch was, jetzt machen wir noch was. Letzte Zeit hier machen wir jetzt noch was. So,
bla, bla, SSL-Zert. So, und jetzt passt mal auf, wie kaputt das Ganze ist. Setup. Wir
generieren jetzt mal ein SSL, ein Self-Signed SSL-Zertifikat. Weil, ich mein, wir wollen
ja einen HTTPS, also einen TLS-Webserver mit SSL haben. Und dazu müssen wir natürlich
irgendein Zertifikat hinterlegen auf dem Webserver, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
So, also, KeySize, das hier, wir fancy company, unser Name, das sind die Sachen, die dann
später im Zertifikat drinne stehen. Also, unsere Firma, also, Organization, heißt CACW
und der Name, wofür das Ganze ausgestellt wird, 122168, 100, nee, keine Ahnung, ist
ein Scheiß egal. Vollkommen egal. Es geht eh nicht. So, laufe ich bis 2030, wunderbar.
So, jetzt passt mal auf. Ich will euch nur mal zeigen, wie toll die Library funktioniert.
Blablabla, funktioniert. Wir lagen jetzt mal hoch. Also, was der jetzt machen sollte
ist, ein neues Zertifikat generieren und dann ausgeben, hat funktioniert. Nee, gar
nicht. Ja, das hat funktioniert, gibt er nicht aus. Einfach nicht ausgeben, er hat
funktioniert. Aber ich kann euch schon mal spoilern, das Zertifikat generieren funktioniert
nicht. Warum, weiß ich nicht. Es ist natürlich für einen HTTPS-SSL-Webserver schon mal sehr
schlecht, wenn das Zertifikate-Generieren nicht funktioniert. Weil ohne Zertifikate
kein SSL und kein HTTPS und sowas. Deswegen müssen wir die Zertifikate jetzt selber generieren.
Weil die Library bietet das zwar an, aber die ist kaputt. Wir warten jetzt erst mal,
bis er Zertifikate generiert hat. Das dauert ja so 20, 30 Sekunden und dann werdet ihr
gleich sehen, was passiert, wenn er fertig Zertifikate generiert ist. Es kann natürlich
auch sein, dass es jetzt mittlerweile einen neuen Bug gibt, weil das ist ja schon ein
Jahr her, wo ich das ausprobiert habe, dass es jetzt komplett hängt oder so. Mal abwarten.
Schauen wir mal ab, das dauert so eine halbe Minute, die Zertifikate zu generieren. Oliver391
sagt Namespaces C++, ja. Leider kommen wir nicht drum herum. Ich hab mir während der
Zertifikate, nee, ich will es euch ja zeigen, ich will ja, dass wir sehen, wie er crasht.
Craschosaurus rex. Oh, das war Payne's Champ, oder? Kann das sein, dass er gar nichts macht
gerade? Dass er einfach nur hängt? Komplett hängen geblieben. Sollte es, ich kann euch
spoilern, es funktioniert nicht. Zertifikate generieren ist kaputt. Wir sehen es ja gleich.
Ich hab mir nämlich noch was anderes gekauft. Das müssen wir auch demnächst mal im Stream
ausprobieren. Ich hab mir nämlich ein Meadow bestellt. Das ist, den hab ich mir schon vor
2-3 Monaten bestellt. Das ist ein Microcontroller, den man angeblich komplett mit.NET und C
sharp programmieren kann. Mit ziemlich viel Leistung drinne sogar. Oh, was? Moment. Das
Zertifikate-Galerien hat funktioniert? Das ist gestern immer abgekackt? Ja, wie denn
das? Warum geht denn das jetzt? Ich bin begeistert. Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mal mache? Nur für
den Fall der Fälle, dass ich noch mal einen funktionierenden Example brauche hier. Aber
es keck weh, hab ich keck weh gemacht. Get in it. Ich check das mal kurz ein. Geht,
warum auch immer, dass ich es wieder kriege. Okay, das war so nicht geplant, weil gestern
ist es die ganze Zeit abgekackt. Ich mach mal die kleine Key-Size, weil die ist definitiv
immer abgeschissen gestern. Komisch. Ein nicer Vorführeffekt, ja. Hallo Marvcat. Unglaublich,
dass was funktioniert, ja. Diese Fehlerbehandlung hier ist auch Wahnsinn. Das funktioniert?
Es funktioniert einfach. So, dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob der Web-Server jetzt auch
funktioniert. So, gut. Also wenn das Zertifikat-Generieren nicht funktioniert, dann sagen wir Restart.
Wir machen noch mal eine weitere Funktion und sagen jetzt in it WLAN, in it Wi-Fi oder
was auch immer. Und da schieben wir den ganzen Kram hier rein und rufen das in it Wi-Fi
hier auf, weil ich will meinen Setup-Funktion ein bisschen sauberer halten, dass ich durchblicke,
was da eigentlich passiert. Nur durch die Kraft des Q-Chats tatsächlich, ja. Nur dadurch,
ohne Scheiß, Leute, ich hab das Gleiche gestern probiert. Der ist mir bei jedem Zertifikat-Generieren
verreckt. Ich hab keinen Schimmer, warum das jetzt funktioniert. Ich will mich ja nicht
beschweren, dass es geht. So, jetzt haben wir nen Zertifikat. Jetzt haben wir nen Server.
Was macht der jetzt hier? Der gute Server-Start. Ja. Server. Also wir haben jetzt nen Zertifikat.
Hiernach haben wir nen Zertifikat. Wir weisen das Zertifikat dem Server zu, sagen ihm
noch, wir wollen auf Port 443 lauschen. Müssen wir nicht. Das ist Default. Und wir wollen
20-20 Verbindungen maximal. 20 ist viel zu viel. Das kann das Ding wahrscheinlich eh
nicht ab. Was sind die Sternchen in C++-Kommentare? Nee. Welche? Sternchen? Ah, hier. Da ist ein
Pointer. Nicht zu verwechseln mit dem da. Das ist eine Speicheradresse. Ein Pointer ist
keine, nicht nur eine Speicheradresse. Das hier ist eine Speicheradresse. Das hier ist
eine Kombination aus Speicheradresse und Typ. Das ist der Unterschied zwischen Pointer und
Speicheradresse. Das war eigentlich so im Nachhinein, war das eine ziemlich kurz und
knackige Erklärung für Pointer, oder? Pointer ist eine Speicheradresse und ein Typ. Das ist
eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Erklärung. Big, big brain. Ah, yes. Excellent. Danke Max,
das wird mir bei meiner Klausur helfen. Also wenn der Lehrer sagt, das ist falsch, dann
ist er ein Kacknoob. So, also Server gestartet. Hier, Server start, müssen wir jetzt noch
eine Webseite oder irgendwas, wo man was abrufen kann vom Web-Server. So, brauchen wir noch
Funktionen. Übrigens, jetzt noch mal was schönes C++-mäßiges, was mich auch schon
wieder komplett verwirrt. Wobei, machen wir nachher, machen wir nachher, weil es könnte
sein, dass es hier tatsächlich sogar funktioniert. Update und wir wollen da einen Post machen,
weil wir wollen ja unsere neue Firmware hochschieben. Lehrer sind halt öfters Kacknoobs als einem
Lieb ist. Das ist korrekt. Excellent. So sieht's aus. Wo hat er hier die Funktion? Die Funktion
für, das nennen wir übrigens nicht Handle Root. Handle Root wäre ein ziemlich blöder
Name dafür. Das nennen wir Handle Update, weil wir den Update hochpushen und wir machen
den ganzen Klempel raus. So, yes. Handle Update. So, man könnte jetzt hier annehmen und das
jetzt mal kompilieren, mal gucken, dass das funktioniert. Ja, funktioniert. Man könnte
jetzt hier annehmen und wahrscheinlich, dank der Macht des QChat, funktioniert wahrscheinlich
das auch, aber ich hab's gestern probiert mit einer Websocket-Verbindung, da hat es
nicht funktioniert, weil ich zu doof war, die richtige Syntax zu finden, wahrscheinlich.
Man könnte jetzt davon ausgehen, es würde sich hier anbieten, wenn man was Kleines,
hier einen kleinen Funktionsaufruf programmieren will, der nur ein paar Zeilen lang ist, dann
würde es sich anbieten, das über einen Lambda-Aufruf zu machen, würde man denken, weil das hat
der C++ mittlerweile. Also sprich, dass wir nicht eine extra Funktion hier oben definieren,
die aufgerufen wird, wenn einer einen Postrequest auf diese Uhr macht, sondern ein Lambda-Request
und ich hab's gestern mit Websocket-Verbindung versucht, das hat uns verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert. So, anscheinend, anscheinend ist das eben eine
Websocket-Problem. Gut, das würde funktionieren, aber wir machen es trotzdem mit einer eigenen
Funktion. C++ Pros, wofür ist das und hier davor? Weil das geht mit und und ohne und.
Wo ist da der Unterschied? Warum geht das mit und ohne und, was bedeutet das und überhaupt?
An der Stelle. Es kann keine Adresse, es kann keine, es kann ja keine, keine Referenz sein
an der Stelle. Oder doch, oder nicht? Was ist das und an der Stelle? Ich verstehe, C++
leuchtet mir an manchen Sachen einfach nicht ein. Wie kommst du immer auf die Musik? Ich
hab ne Playlist mit tausend besten Nintendo-Songs. Aber ich glaub nicht, dass das an der Stelle
hier ne Referenz ist zu dieser komischen Funktion, weil warum geht es mit und und ohne und?
Was hat Max überhaupt vor? Ich will meine Microcontroller über WLAN mit neuer Firmware
updaten können und das Ganze über HTTPS. Und ich hab mir wieder so ein Thema rausgesucht,
was vor mir anscheinend noch keiner gemacht hat. Und wohlgemerkt nicht einfach die Firmware
abrufen, sondern die Firmware pushen zum Controller. Und es gibt einfach nix Fertiges und es gibt
keinen, der das gemacht hat vorher. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich immer so komische, so
komische Dinge mir aussuche. So, ähm, jetzt müssen wir noch dem Server sagen, dass er
auch unter slash update das Ganze verwenden soll. Das nennen wir das Ganze nennen wir
nicht Node, das nennen wir Update-Node. So. Und wenn ich das jetzt hoch lade, dann sollte
ich mit Curl schon mal drauf zugreifen können. Und da sehen wir schon das erste Problem dieser
Library. Und zwar, dass sie endlos schleifen, fabriziert, die ich nicht außer einem ESP
neustart beheben kann. Werdet ihr gleich sehen. Zeig euch gleich. Über HTTPS, äh, ein Dodo,
über HTTPS ist es relativ einfach. Äh, Secure Server Loop müssen wir noch. Hallo? Ok. Warum
ist das jetzt denn? Ah, weil da Pointer. Dann sind die Beispiele komisch. Man macht
das mit Pointer, man macht das hier als Referenz und man macht das als globale Variable. Ok,
das ist auch wurscht. Ähm, machen wir das so. Hochladen. So, und dann greifen wir mit
nem Curl drauf zu. Curl auf OE. Warte mal, was hat das Ding? Äh, welcher IP hat's gekriegt?
Ich hab's gar nicht geguckt. Mal kurz mal schauen, was das Ding für ne IP kriegt. Ja,
das ist, das ist in C++ nicht immer so einfach. Und ist nicht immer Adresse. Zum Beispiel
hier ist das und was anderes. Die mögen in C++ doppelte, doppelte Bedeutung von Dingern.
Oh ne, äh, ja, Adresse. Die sind eben Meister in doppelten, doppelte, doppeldeutigen Sachen
in C++. Ok, jetzt versuchen wir mal unsere Firmware hochzuladen. Ich mein, die wird nicht
funktionieren, aber, ähm, dass ihr mal seht, was passiert, wenn man's probiert. Also, wir
machen jetzt den Curl und zwar ignorieren wir mal alle Zertifikate und rufen einfach
nur mal die, die Adresse auf. Gut. Sagt der New Connection. Funktioniert nicht, weil es
ist ja kein Post. Also sagen wir ihm, wir wollen das mit, als Post machen. Ich hab's
ja hier als HTTP Post registriert. Ah, funktioniert auch. So, und wenn wir da jetzt was hochladen
und zwar mit, äh, Binary, äh, Data, Binary. Genau, und jetzt laden wir mal unsere Firmware
hoch. Ich glaub, Add, oder? Oh ne, äh. Curl. Ja, wo ist unsere Firmware? Build. Firmware
bin. Pst, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich ein Add davor machen muss. So, ähm. Was
ein Add. Ah, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert der Upload, genau. So, und jetzt seht ihr schon
ein Problem. Wenn ich das jetzt abbreche, was ja durchaus mal sein kann, dass ich den
Upload abbrechen will, dann wird das Ding jetzt gleich in der Endlosschleife hängen
bleiben. Gegen die ich nichts tun kann. Weil das irgendwie diese komische Web-Server-Library
äh, intern macht. Das Einzige, was ich an der Stelle machen kann, ist, ich hab alles
ausprobiert, Leute. Ich hab heute Morgen zwei Stunden daran rumgedockt, ich habe keinen
Weg gefunden, dem Ding zu sagen, Scheiß auf die, was juckt ihn überhaupt, Connections,
die geschlossen wurden. Ich habe dazu keine Lösung gefunden. Ich hab sogar auf GitHub
geguckt, das haben andere Leute über diesen Fehler berichtet und gibt kein Ergebnis zu.
Das ist natürlich was, das ist komplett für'n Arsch und kann man auf gar keinen Fall so
verwenden. Weil, wenn du mal ein Update pusht, ja, übrigens der Server ist jetzt auch kaputt,
da geht jetzt, da geht das nicht mehr, ne. Der ist jetzt, der ist jetzt hinüber. Der
muss ich jetzt neu starten. Also ne ganz schlechte Situation für ne Sache, die irgendwo in der
Wand steckt, die ich nicht einfach so neu starten kann. Also sprich, wenn ich, wenn
ich den Upload cancel, dann gehts kaputt. Das ist schon mal absoluter Fail. Keine Ahnung,
was sie da zurecht programmiert haben. Und ihr seht, ich mache noch nichts. Also es kann,
es kann gar nicht an mir liegen, weil mein Handle-Funktionier ist komplett leer. So,
das ist das erste Problem, was ich mit der Library hatte. Dass die Endlosschleifen fabriziert
gegen die ich nichts machen kann. Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir machen Monka Big
Brain Lösung. Und zwar, ich zeig euch jetzt mal die Big Brain Lösung. Und zwar, machen
wir jetzt ne Schleife. Und wir starten den ESP einfach neu, wenn der Web-Server hängt.
Es ist zwar ne mega hässliche Lösung, aber sie funktioniert. Das heißt, sollte der Web-Server
hängen, starten wir den ESP neu. Wenn ihr ne bessere Idee habt, schießt los, ja. So
und was ich da rausgekriegt habe, wie man jetzt lesen kann, was man hier, also was das
Curl macht hier ist folgendes, minus K ignoriert das Server-Zertifikat. Weil mein Server-Zertifikat
ist natürlich nicht gültig. Weder das hier noch meine Organisation KeckW und die Zertifizierungsstelle
ist nicht gültig. Also Curl wird auf jeden Fall meckern, Zertifikat ist ungültig. So,
das macht minus K insecure. X sagt, die Methode, die er verwenden soll, sich zum Server zu
verbinden, das ist ein Postrequest. Das ist kein Get-Request, wie man hier sieht, hab
ich auch eingestellt. Das Update ist quasi geroutet nur für Hostrequests. Hat der Controller
einen Watchdog Timer? Ähm, ja. Ja, aber der schlägt nicht zu an der Stelle. Oder ich
müsste den irgendwie von Hand reinbauen oder so. Den hab ich aber noch nie gemacht. Der
schlägt nicht zu, weil die Main-Loop läuft weiter. Das juckt dir nicht. Aber das könnte
ich machen, irgendeinen Timeout setzen. Irgendeinen Timeout setzen und wenn es bis dahin nicht
resettet ist, dann starte neu. Irgendwie sowas. Ähm, aber ich zeig euch jetzt mal, was ich
mir überlegt hab. Zumindest, er geht auf diese Uhr und postet dann unsere Firmware, unser
Firmware-Binary, postet er, also schickt er an den Web-Server vom Controller. So, und
deswegen hab ich überlegt, was wir machen können. Das hab ich im Vorfeld natürlich
schon mal ausprobiert. Sonst wäre das hier komplett hereinfallen. Und zwar, man kann
gucken, ist Request complete? Das heißt, wir machen jetzt in meinem Händler in die
Funktion mal eine Schleife rein, die so lange läuft, bis ich diesen kompletten Request
eingelesen hab. Also quasi alles, bis ich alles eingelesen hab. So, und, ähm, jetzt
muss ich grad mal gucken, an welcher Stelle ich das hier mache. Genau, und jetzt lesen
wir erstmal den Request ein. Dazu brauchen wir einen Array mit, der war irgendwie mal
ein Buffer mit, ähm, keine Ahnung, 512 Bytes. Request, Read. Und zwar readen wir jetzt,
size, in den Buffer, also sprich, wir lesen jetzt das hier ein, on the fly, was wir hier
hoch uploaden gerade. So, äh, also read Bytes in den Buffer, äh, mit der Länge 512. Also,
wir lesen so viele Bytes ein, wie in unseren Buffer reinpassen. So, äh, was wir jetzt
auch sehen werden ist, dass es, ich zeige euch mal, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Wir lassen uns jetzt mal hier ausgeben, die, ähm, Request, Konter, also die Länge, die
noch drinnen ist in dem Buffer, und ihr werdet sehen, dass es bei jedem Durchlauf, wird das
weniger. Und jetzt, ich machte, ich führte es jetzt erstmal aus, danach zeige ich euch
mal den Trick, den ich mir überlegt hab, was wir machen können. Aber erstmal uploaden
wir das Teil. Oh, im Chat, man, big brain Sachen. Ähm, schreibe das ganze mit Python, lösen
sich viele da, nee, nee, nee, in dem Fall nicht. Hab ich mir kurzzeitig überlegt, heute
Morgen, ob ich das machen soll. Erstens, findest du auch wenig zu, ähm, MicroPython, ESP32
mit SSL-Unterstützung. Scheint wohl zu gehen, aber wo es komplett aufhört, ist, äh, ESP32,
SSL und Secure Websockets in Python. Da schaffst du eine Verbindung und danach stürzt das Ding
mit Out of Memory ab, hab ich auf GitHub gefunden. Dazu kommt, dass du aus MicroPython die ganzen
C-Libraries nicht verwenden kannst, die du für irgendwelche Sensoren und Hardware brauchst.
Du musst halt hoffen, dass es welche dafür gibt. So, ähm, ich lade jetzt mal was hoch
und dann werdet ihr sehen, der Upload an sich funktioniert. Guckt die, seht ihr, die Content-Länge
wird immer weniger. Also sprich, der Uploadet hier und ich zeig euch jetzt mal den krassen,
den, den, den Über-Curl-Hack, den, den keiner kennt. Hier habt ihr, hier habt ihr ihn zuerst
gesehen, Leute. Jetzt zeig ich euch, er war übrigens fertig mit Uploaden. Pass mal auf,
den über-krassen Curl-Hack. Wisst ihr, dass ihr bei Curl angeben könnt? Procress, Procress
Bar und dann passiert nichts, wenn ihr das angibt. Ist euch vielleicht auch schon mal
aufgefallen, dass die Procress Bar bei Curl nicht funktioniert? Guckt, die Procress Bar
funktioniert nicht. Und jetzt zeig ich euch, was ihr machen müsst, dass die Procress Bar
funktioniert. Übrigens, ich kann jetzt nicht abbrechen, wenn ich jetzt abbreche, hänge
ich wieder Endlosschleife drinnen. So, und jetzt zeig ich euch, jetzt zeig ich euch
mit Tricks 17. Ihr müsst das ganze pipen nach Def Null und schon habt ihr eine Procress
Bar. Wieso? Ganz hundertprozentig habe ich es auch nicht verstanden. Anscheinend ist
es so, dass Curl den Standard Out benutzt für Response vom Server. Und quasi Response
vom Server irgendwie mit der Procress Bar konkurriert. Und wenn ich das ganze, also
T-Splitter das ganze Jahr in der Datei und Standard Out, und wenn ich den Standard Out
dann umleite nach Def Null und Curl irgendwie denkt, und Curl irgendwie denkt, ich habe,
ich möchte den Standard Out vom Server Response nicht haben, dann zeigt er, dann zeigt er
die Procress Bar an. Ich weiß auch nicht, wer sich das wieder überlegt hat. Das ist
Matt, also eigentlich ist das nicht Big Brain, das ist ziemlich, ziemlich Low Brain von Curl
Entwicklern. Man kann es den Leuten auch einfacher machen. Aber wenn ihr bei Curl eine Procress
Bar haben wollt, dann müsst ihr es nach T-pipen und das T als Datei in die gesplittet wird
Def Null. Dann macht Curl eine Procress Bar. Six header. Ok, so. Und jetzt zeige ich euch
mal den Trick, den ich mir überlegt habe, was wir machen können, dass das System nicht
mehr in der Endlosschleife hängen bleibt. So, und zwar, ja. So, und zwar was wir machen
ist, wir speichern uns, also sprich wir merken uns, wie viele Bites wir schon eingelesen
haben. Also sprich, da sagen wir hier File Length plus gleich S. Also sprich in S oder
nennen wir es mal, man könnte es auch Size nennen oder ich könnte es auch direkt da
reinschreiben lassen. Das ist wahrscheinlich eher C-Style, dass es ein bisschen kryptischer
aussieht, noch alles. Was der jetzt macht ist, der liest quasi von dem, was ich uploade
in diesen Buffer und die Funktion gibt die Menge der gelesenen Bites zurück. Das heißt
in File Length haben wir quasi nach jedem Durchlauf dieser Schleife drinne stehen, wie
viele Sachen wir eingelesen haben. Laut Stack Overflow würde sogar Curl Procress Barket
ausreichen. Aha, können wir gleich mal ausprobieren. So, und was wir jetzt machen ist, einmal,
hier drinne werden wir unsere Firmware updaten, also sprich, wir brauchen es übrigens doch
als eigene Variable. So, wenn wir was eingelesen haben, dann machen wir hier Firmware to Flash,
dann speichern wir das neue Zeug auf dem internen Flash Speicher. Weil wenn wir was eingelesen
haben, möchten wir es ja speichern, dass wir Rebooten können und die neue Firmware ist
da. So, und was wir jetzt aber machen, jetzt kommt mal, was sehr eklig ist, wieso nicht
File Length größer Null, das wirst du gleich sehen. Weil File Length ja nach dem ersten
Durchlauf immer größer Null ist. Und es bei jedem Durchlauf neu gesetzt wird und was
wir jetzt machen ist, aber der Patrick ist da schon auf dem richtigen Weg, jetzt gucken
wir, lsif, wenn File Length größer Null ist, und dann bedeutet das nämlich, in dem
Fall, s ist nicht größer Null, das heißt, wir wechseln in diesen lsif rein. Also sprich,
wenn wir in diesem lsif ankommen, bedeutet das, s ist kleiner gleich Null. Also Null in
dem Fall, weil er kann nicht negativ lesen. So, und das heißt, wenn wir jetzt hier haben,
also in dem Fall, ich schreib's mal aus, s gleich gleich Null ist es in dem Fall, das
ist aber impliziert schon, weil sonst würden wir hier gar nicht ankommen. Aber ich schon
was eingelesen habe, dann bedeutet das, der Client hat abgebrochen. Es könnte natürlich
auch bedeuten, mein Client ist einfach unglaublich langsam, aber dann hab ich nen Bug drinnen.
So, und in dem Fall, wenn das hier zusammen eintritt, dann würde das nämlich bedeuten,
mein Server bleibt in der Endlosschleife hängen. Und deswegen machen wir an dieser Stelle einfach
die Holzhammer-Methode und restarten den ESP. Ist das nicht ne schöne Lösung? So, jetzt
gucken wir mal, ob der ganze Kram funktioniert. Big Brain-Lösung, Big Brain-Time, Alter.
Das ist übel, ich kann nix dagegen machen, dass das Ding Endlosschleife produziert. Ich
könnte jetzt die Library downloaden, als es geht, klonen hier nach lib rein und versuchen
den Fehler bei dem zu fixen, aber hab ich ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock drauf. So,
und jetzt passt mal auf, was passiert. Jetzt starte ich den Upload. Upload. Server restarten,
das sag ich gleich mal zu. Upload, so, jetzt brech ich ab und jetzt kackt der Server ab
und BAM, ESP startet sich neu. Funktioniert und geht wieder von vorne los, sehr schön.
Funktioniert. Server neu starten geht nicht, weil, wenn man sagt, also ich hab's ausprobiert.
Server. Ich kann's noch mal machen, vielleicht geht. What the fuck. Mein Visual Studio Code
hat sich grad beendet. Java-Script in 2020. Java-Script in 2020. Ich mein, wir können
das mal ausprobieren. Anstatt, anstatt hier neu zu starten, mach ich mal, Secure Server
stopp. Hallo, ah nee, stopp und Secure Server start. Also, ich hab das nämlich schon ausprobiert
und das Phänomen, was ich dann hatte, ist, dass, ähm, der hier blockt und meine Main
Loop gar nicht mehr läuft. Also sprich, der Server ist nicht stopp- und startbar, der geht
dann kaputt. Was natürlich auch für die herausragende Qualität dieser Library spricht. Dass es
eine stopp- und startfunktion gibt, die aber nicht funktioniert. Controller willst du
nicht uploaden? Controller willst du nicht uploaden? Ach, wie wär's? Press F. So, ähm,
ich zieh mal raus. Machen wir da rein. Nee, also Patrick, ich hab das vorher mehr an unterschiedlichsten,
ähm, ich hab das vorher an unterschiedlichen Sachen ausprobiert. Ich hab auch ein extra
Task aufgemacht und hab das Handling von Server starten, stoppen, äh, quasi gemacht, nachdem
ich aus der Funktion raus bin, in einem extra, in einem extra Thread noch mal. Und ich hab
vorher extra in der, in der Main Schleife gesagt, wenn ich grad in der Fehlerbahn bin,
dann nicht ausführen. Also, es hat nicht, es hat nicht funktioniert. Aber wir können
ja mal gucken, vielleicht kriegen wir, vielleicht kriegen wir es jetzt ja gebacken. Also so funktioniert
es definitiv nicht. Das hab ich nämlich schon ausprobiert. Guck, wenn ich jetzt hier was
uploade, lass mal warten, bis der anfängt. Upload läuft, sprech ich ab und... What? Der,
der startet, stoppt jetzt die ganze Zeit den Server und das juckt den überhaupt nicht.
Das war jetzt natürlich ziemlich bescheuert, weil ich hätte hier nochmal sagen müssen,
return. Ähm, ja, abbrechen müsste ich das Ganze auch schon. Oder, oder was heißt return,
wir können auch einfach sagen, break, haben wir das gleiche raus. Also Patrick, ich hab's
vorher ausprobiert, der blockt irgendwie komplett. Aber vielleicht kriegen wir es ja hin. Machen
wir noch kurz Zeit. Und wisst ihr, was das geile ist? Ähm, ich muss morgen nicht aufstehen
früh, ich kann wieder Homeoffice machen. So, äh, ein Command für die Playlist, könnte
man machen. Äh, mach so einen Check, ob die Daten, die ankommen, auch wirklich valid sind.
Ja, es ist, es ist eine TCP-Verbindung, also ich würde mal sagen, dass übertragungsmäßig
sollte nichts kaputt gehen. Aber ja, du hast recht, man sollte, man sollte eigentlich nochmal
ne Check-Summe machen. Das wäre, das schreib ich immer als To-Do auf. So, guckt und jetzt
hängt, hängt meine Main-Loop. Geht nichts mehr. Nach Start, Stop vom Server. Und wenn
ich dann nochmal versuche, was hochzuladen, ist Crash angesagt. Bam, in your face, kaputt.
Aber wir können, wir können es mal probieren, vielleicht kriegen wir, vielleicht kriegen
wir es ja gebacken. Ähm, ok, da schreiben wir noch einen To-Do auf. Äh, was hab ich
grad gesagt? Ja, Leute, mein Hirn. Äh, Check-Summe. Check-Summe. Gucken wir mal, was wir machen.
So, also das heißt, das, das, das funktioniert so an der, an der Stelle, an der, an der Stelle
schon mal nicht. Was wir machen können ist, das hab ich vorher auch schon mal ausprobiert,
wir können sowas hier mit dem Bool, keine Ahnung, Handle, Error, is false. So, dann
können wir an der Stelle sagen, nicht Handle, nicht Handle, Error. Handler, Error. Handler-Error
ist true. So, dann geht er raus. Dann gehen wir in unsere Main-Schleife rein und sagen
hier, aber wie gesagt, ich hab's vorhin ausprobiert, das hat nicht funktioniert. Aber, weißt
ihr nicht, die Macht des Qt-Chats ist, ist ja, ist ja heute, äh, kann viel ausrichten,
ja. Also, if Handler-Error, dann, ähm, sagen wir, Secure, Secure-Server, Stop. Ups. Stop.
Da machen wir nochmal ein Delay rein. Ah, man weiß ja nie. Wir machen mal, wir machen
mal ein Delay davor, ein Delay danach, man kann nicht genug delayen an der Stelle. Und
dann ist aber Start. So, ähm, else, Handler-Error setzen wir wieder auf false. Und hier machen
wir die Loop rein. So, Patrick, sowas in der Richtung meinste, ne? Ich mein, das ist zwar
nicht so ganz so schön, ähm, weil wir das als nächsten Durchlauf machen, aber es sollte
funktionieren. Aber ich hab's ausprobiert, funktioniert nicht. Aber vielleicht, vielleicht
funktioniert's ja doch. Wir können's noch locken oder sowas. Denn der Händler sollte
eigentlich aufgerufen werden, hier, wenn ich in der Loop drinnen bin. Weil, wozu, wozu
muss ich's sonst machen? So, als Upload starten. Pointer, Pogger, sieben Monate, dankeschön.
Abbrechen. Bäm. Klein Closed. Und die Main Loop läuft nicht mehr. Also sprich, ähm,
der hängt, der hängt, der ist hier noch drinnen, der ist mit der Loop noch gar nicht fertig.
Also, müsste man irgendwie, irgendwie einmal warten oder so, bis er mit der Loop raus ist.
Aber das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein. Der kann nicht in der Loop hängen, weil er ist
hier, wenn er stoppen muss. Also, der stoppt, der stoppt ja nur, wenn Händler-Error ist.
Das heißt, er geht nie aus dieser Loop raus. Das ist total fail. Ähm, mach den trotzdem
mal volatile. Was denn? Was soll ich volatile machen? Den Händlerror. Muss man das zuerst
schrei-, äh, wie schreibt man das Wort? Ne, vor-, so. Macht man das zuerst? D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Huge Upload Speed. Was ist denn volatile? Das krieg ich aus dem Kopf nicht genau hin.
Das ist irgendeine Compiler-Anweisung, dass er Dinger, Dinger nicht macht, die er normalerweise
optimieren würde. Ich glaub, das ist, das ist, ich glaub, das ist, äh, Optimierung
ausschalten. Ja, genau. Also, Patrick, der kennt sich damit aus. So. Upload läuft, zack.
Ah, Grip. Also, für'n Arsch. So. Das-, deswegen, so, so Dinger hab ich auch schon rumprobiert
heute Morgen. Ähm, was ne Kack-Library. So meine Worte. Übelster Crap. Aber die einzige,
die es gibt. Deswegen bin ich hier auf meinen Neustart gekommen. Ich gestehe, dass ich
kaum was verstehe, aber trotzdem gern im Stream schimmel. Das ist schön, wenn du so
gerne da bist. Wenn du willst, dass ich dir was erklär, äh, kann ich das jetzt erklären?
Ich mein, ich kann jetzt nicht die komplette, äh, nicht vom ersten If an erklären, aber
wenn du konkrete Fragen hast, schieß immer, immer los, schieße, ne? Kannst du nicht einfach
im Restobjekt einen Statuscode setzen und damit aus der Funktion-, ich geh doch aus der Funktion
raus. Hier, guck mal. Ich geh ja hier raus. Break und danach ist Schluss. Hier ist vorbei.
Also der, der geht nach Break raus. Ich mein, ich kann den Return machen, aber das dürfte
jetzt keinen großen Unterschied machen. Ja. Aber in Rest ist nichts gesetzt. Das macht
keinen Unterschied. Ähm, das macht keinen Unterschied. Das hab ich auch schon ausprobiert.
Aber wie gesagt, die Library ist busy, ähm, kaputt. Wir können aber ruhig noch ein bisschen
rumprobieren das nächste Mal. Ähm, ich hab jetzt nicht mehr allzu viel Zeit. Wir können
ruhig das nächste Mal rumprobieren, ob wir das irgendwie noch gebacken kriegen. Also
ich bleib jetzt erstmal bei meiner Geschichte hier. Ich lass ihn jetzt erst mal restarten.
Einfach die Hardcore-Variante restart. Ich würd jetzt gerne noch mal ganz kurz probieren,
ob der Sache, das Firmware-Update noch ein bisschen näher kommt. Und zwar, was er jetzt
hier her macht ist, er liest ja das ein, was ich pushe zum Server. Und das heißt, an der
Stelle kann ich meine Firmware schreiben. Ähm, am besten sollte ich natürlich danach zumindest
noch mal oder on the fly in irgendeiner Form, wie auch immer ich das am besten mache, muss
ich mir mal überlegen. Ähm, Check-Summe drüber machen. Aber wir scheißen jetzt mal auf Check-Summe.
Ja, ich mein, im Zweifelsfall, ich hab's per USB dran und ich kann's immer neu flashen.
Man kann's ja gar nicht komplett kaputt machen. Ich kann's ja nur kaputt machen, dass ich
über WLAN nicht mehr flashen kann. So, hauen wir mal das Update-Header rein, wo man ESP32
und ESP266 Updates mitmachen kann. Jancu300, schön, dass du da bist. Er schreibt, es ist
so schön, deine Stimmen zu hören, Max. Kenne dich schon seit den ersten Tagen. Es ist nice,
dass du den Weg in den Stream gefunden hast, auch wenn das hier in dem Stream natürlich
was ganz anderes ist, als auf YouTube. So. Ähm. Mach das mal, Patrick, bester Mann. Such mal.
Aber die Library ist auch nicht schön programmiert, also du wirst Spaß haben. Ähm, gut. Also
wenn man über WLAN ein Update auf dem ESP starten will, dann muss man als erstes erst
mal sagen, Update, äh, Begin. UpdateBegin braucht eine Funktion, ist, äh, äh, braucht
als Parameter, ähm, wie groß das Update ist. Dass es checken kann, ob es genug Platz hat.
Das heißt, man muss jetzt erst mal hier gucken, dass wir uns mal speichern, wie groß, wie
groß meine, wie groß mein Update ist, also dass die Firmware, die ich hier hoch lade,
wie groß die ist, das kriege ich ja aus Content-Length raus. Jetzt kann ich sagen, ok, wenn genug
Platz ist auf deinem internen Flash, dann leg los. Ähm, das heißt, ich muss das jetzt
natürlich noch überprüfen, sonst wäre das... Was hatte der jetzt für Schmerzen? Ah, yes,
Visual Studio Code zeigt Blödsinn an. Äh, was programmierst du grad da? Äh, eine Möglichkeit,
dass ich über WLAN eine neue Firmware auf meinen Microcontroller pushen kann. Ähm,
über HTTPS. Pushen, nicht pullen. Warum Pointer statt Referenzen? Hä? Auf was beziehst du
dich? In dem Fall ist ganz einfach, weil die Library das so haben will. Das ist ein ESP32,
das ist ein ESP32, den ich hier grad hab. Ich hab so einen hier, am Start, dafür. Äh,
Stein des Anstoßes, oder warum ich das jetzt mache, ist eigentlich das. Ich hab ja meine
Klingel etwas smarter gemacht, mit einem ESP32, mit so einem, der steckt in der Gegensprechanlage
in der Wand. Und die Update-Funktion, die ich da aktuell drauf hab, ist ein wenig fehleranfällig.
Ich hab's schon geschafft, das Ding... Da gibt's keine fertigen Lösungen für HTTPS,
gibt's nicht. Ähm, für HTTPS ist es easy, mit HTTPS ist es schwierig, findste ganz wenig
dagegen. Äh, findste ganz wenig dazu. Und ich hab' das hier in der Wand stecken und
ich hab's ja schon mal geschafft, das Ding zu deadlocken, also über WLAN-Update. Bisschen
verkackt. Deswegen wollte ich jetzt mal ne ordentliche WLAN-Update-Sache programmieren,
dass ich auch meine Controller updaten kann, die in der Wand verbaucht sind, ohne dass ich
Gefahr laufe, dass ich erstmal Strom ausschalten muss überall. So, also wir müssen jetzt gucken,
ob genug Platz ist. So, wenn Update-Beginn nicht funktioniert, dann sagen wir Update-Print-Error
auf unseren Debug-Ausgabe. Smart-Klingel. Ja, hab ich im letzten Stream erzählt, was
ich gemacht hab. Und zwar, ich hab' immer ganz kurz gesagt, ich hab' ne Siedeltelefonanlage
aus, da hab' ich nen ESP32 in das Gegensprech-Apparat eingebaut. Also nicht eben auf der Straße,
sondern in dem Handgerät. Ich zeig's euch. Ich hab' doch hier letztens, wo hab ich denn
das Bild dafür? Post. Image. Äh, wo... Wo hatte ich denn Punkt CC? Ah, Leute, wo hatte
ich denn das, das letztens auf hier? Hatt' ich das auf Windows auf oder hatt' ich das?
Fuck. Wo hatt' ich das denn auf? Okay, hier schonmal nicht. Ich hab' doch ein Bild von
dem gemacht. Wo ist denn meine History? History. History. Post. Wo ist das denn? Bin ich jetzt
total hängen geblieben? Wo... Wo ist mein Bild? Das war Picture-Upload, jaja. Irgendwas
mit Post war das. Picture. Aber warum ist das nicht in der Historie drin? Das verwirrt
mich viel mehr. Hatte man das vielleicht in Chrome offen? Post. Ein farbiger Stuhl Abdeckung.
Äh. Äh. Tja, Leute. RIP. Keine Ahnung mehr, wo das hin ist. Das war... Irgendwas mit Punkt
Post Image. Punkt CC oder irgendwie sowas war das, glaub' ich. Ja. Post Image. Hatte
man das hochgeladen? Sag' mal. Das kann doch nicht sein. Warum ist das nicht in der Historie
drin? Hatte man das vielleicht in Firefox auf? Ah nee, das ist ja der Firefox. Hatte man
das dann vielleicht in Chrome auf? Warte mal, ist das in Chrome oder in Firefox? History.
Vor zwei Tagen. CC. Ich hab' kein Schimmer vor das Bild hin. Das ist echt nicht... Sehr
merkwürdig. Ähm. Na gut. Wie dem... Wie dem Ausseier. Irgendwie... Man hat überall
History und jeder lockt was mit, aber wenn er mal was mitlocken soll, dann geht's nicht.
Das ist echt nicht merkwürdig. Wie... Der Chat weiß es wieder. Der Chat weiß es. Hier.
Der Chat weiß es. Da ist das Bild. Krass. Woher der Chat das wieder weiß. So. Und dahinter.
Hinter diesem Gegensprechgerät. Da steckt ein ESP32 in der Wand. In der Dose. Und es
ist ziemlich doof, wenn man das Ding updaten will. Wenn sich's aufhängt beim Update. Weil
man Scheiße programmiert hat. Weil da muss man das Ganze abmachen und die Strom abmachen
und die Strom wieder reinmachen. Das sackt massiv. Und deswegen will ich jetzt ein ordentlicher
Updatevorgang programmieren. Und ich will das Update halt pushen auf den ESP. Und ich
will... Das hab ich mir in den Kopf gesetzt. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich dumm. Ich will
das über HTTPS machen. Über HTTPS ist es gar kein Problem. Gibt sogar fertige Sachen
vorne und selbst zu programmieren. Ist auch total easy. Über HTTPS gibt's kaum was.
Und was macht der ESP in der Telefonanlage? Der ist nicht in der Telefonanlage. Das ist
nur dieses Gegensprechding. Telefon von der Tür-Gegensprechanlage. Der ist da angeschlossen
und guckt, ob's klingelt. Und zwar folgendermaßen. Da ist so eine kleine, wirklich nur aus vier
Bauteilen Schaltung dran. Die quasi guckt, welche Spannung auf der Leitung drauf ist.
Und wenn 24 Volt oder größer 20 Volt auf der Leitung sind, signalisiert das Ding damit,
dass es klingelt. Und wenn es das feststellt, dass es klingelt, dann schickt es eine Nachricht
an meine Heimautomatisierung. Und meine Heimautomatisierung schaltet das Tablet an. Und das Tablet zeigt
mir die Kamera von der Tür und vom Hof. Und das natürlich schon, bevor ich überhaupt
am Gerät dran bin. Weil das geht schnell. Das dauert, bis der Browser hier offen ist,
dauert das eine halbe Sekunde. Das geht wirklich flutsch. In der Zeit bin ich garantiert nicht
an der Gegensprechanlage. Und ich hab noch ein Magnetsensor, also ein Sensor, der Magnetfelder
erkennt. Hier hinter das Telefon auf der anderen Seite gepappt. Weil das Telefon hat ein Magnet
drinne. Und mit dem Magnetsensor erkenne ich auch noch, an welcher Station der Hörer abgenommen
wurde. Also sprich, wenn ich hier den Hörer abnehme, dann kriegt es der ESP auch mit über
den Magnetsensor. Und da kann ich beispielsweise auch dann das Tablet wieder ausschalten direkt
sobald jemand auflegt und sowas. Das ist echt nice. Hat auch ein bisschen Gehirnschmalz
gebraucht, muss ich sagen. Ist das Tablet am Dauerstrom? Ja. Also hier dahinter, ich
mach euch mal ein paar Bilder das nächste Mal. Mach euch mal ein paar Bilder, kann ich euch
zeigen. Hier dahinter ein Hallsensor, genau. Ein ganz kleiner Hallsensor. So ein 5 Cent
Hallsensor. So ein ganz billigen Kleinen ist dahinter. Kost nix. Hier. Konrad, ich hab
Konrad einen Hallsensor, den billigsten gekauft. Den billigsten, der für 3,3 Volt funktioniert
hat. Hallsensor. Hallsensor. 3,3 oder 5 ist egal. 5 Volt. Hier so, boah, so teuer? Nee,
meiner war deutlich billiger. Hab ich hier einen liegen, dass ich hier mal gucken kann?
Nee. Hallsensor. Hier, so ein Ding. So ein Ding da. Ich glaube nicht, dass es genau
der ist, aber so was in der Richtung ist er. 3,5 Volt, genau, so ein billigen hier. 36
Cent, äh, 86 Cent, Eats. Nee, bei AliExpress kannst du grad nicht bestellen, das dauert
zu lang. So ein billig Ding hab ich dahinter. Also man muss ja sagen, die Bauteile für
diese Geschichte, die haben vielleicht einen Euro gekostet oder so. Also nicht sonderlich
teuer. Nichtsdestotrotz, wir machen im nächsten Stream weiter und dann machen wir dann, schließen
wir das Ganze mit dem Update ab, weil ich weiß jetzt ungefähr wie es funktioniert,
wir haben mal ein bisschen ProCraft gemacht. Äh, ich kann zwar morgen ausschlafen, dank
Homeoffice muss allerdings trotzdem, ähm, 7.30 Uhr oder so Homeoffice anfangen und außerdem
muss ich mal dringend kacken. Ähm, das heißt wir machen das nächste Mal weiter. Ich guck
mal ob es irgendjemand gibt, den ich hosten kann. Du folgst? Wem folge ich denn, der das
brauchen könnte? Mein Gott, manchmal ist die Twitch-Behandhabung aber auch eklig. Äh,
du folgst, ja. Ja. Gibt es da irgendjemand den ich hosten könnte, den er klein ist, den
ich follower und der es brauchen könnte? Den Cyrus, komm wir hosten den Krieger, wir hosten
den Krieger zurück. Der Krieger hat uns das letzte Mal gehostet, hosten wir heute mal
den Krieger. Letztes Mal kamen die ganzen Call of Duty Leute bei uns, da können hier
die Broggers Leute jetzt mal zum Krieger rüber. Auch wenn sich das, ich glaube das Publikum
wirklich mittlerweile kaum noch überschneidet. Bei ihm ist Call of Duty vielleicht ein bisschen
tauchen und bei mir ist hier Hardcore-Programmier-Gedöns angesagt. Ähm, ja. Also, wir raiden den Krieger
Leute, wir sehen uns, ich denke mal morgen, weil ich will den Kram wirklich jetzt mal
langsam fertig machen, wird Zeit. Ähm, ja, wir raiden den Krieger. Der Kanal richtet
sich an Erwachsene, also Leute. Seid brav, ja. Tut wenigstens Erwachsen. Okay, Leute,
wir sehen uns. Bis denn. See you.